you
we
okay before we get into our formal
activity here of executive session today
i've been requested by several uh folks
on the committee here and i absolutely
concur
we'd like to stand and have a moment of
silence for what's going on over in the
ukraine
it's very disappointing
what's going on
i especially am really concerned because
my grandchildren are living in romania
uh right on the border
and they are
very very worried what's going on in in
europe today
so let's stand and have a moment of
science please
and in memory of those that have already
died
thank you very much
okay uh the first bill in the daca today
to be exact
is hb 1533
this bill is relative to health
education curriculum in schools and i'd
like to
recognize representative lakas
for a motion
15 33.50
yes i move ita
representative ford
thank you very much so we have a motion
to itl on hb 1533
made by lycus and second by forward
represent like us would you like to
speak to your
motion
yes we have another bill
coming up
that also has to do with actually
potentially a couple bills that have to
do with this section
and so what we thought we would do
is um put them together and basically i
tl this one
and put all the different bits together
on the one that we have coming up
represent ford
okay
uh it's open to discussion right now
represent luna thank you very much mr
chair um i think that sounds like a a
very good plan and um and i think one of
those bills might be um
hospital uh 1263 that is correct
specifically in the area of studies and
um and and i i think
it would be it would be great for the
community to work with the the advocates
on that on that language that um that
moves that forward so thanks so we'll
we'll support there's a number of areas
within health which
we could improve that area studies with
physical education as well with exercise
and nutrition etc
so let's let's take a healthy look at
that healthy look
at that
yeah
play on words
uh when we get to it so uh we have a
motion then on the table
for itl on 1533 it's not that we're
against the the bill at all it's just
that we have similar bills in the same
area of statute and we're going to move
forward with one of them 1263.
hope we move forward with 1263
yes
any further discussion
not seeing any madam clerk
thank you
bill house bill 1533
relative to health education curriculum
in schools the motion on the table is
ito
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
lacus yes representative moffett yes
representative hopson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno
yes
representative waltz yes
represent cornell yes representative
tanner yes representative ellison
represent mullen yes representative
woodcock
represent porter
represent hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
so the motion of itl carries 18 to one
is there a problem with consent anywhere
thank you
so going on to the next bill which is hb
1015 we could turn to that page please
relative to school district policies
regarding objectionable material i
recognize representative moth for a
motion
thank you miss chair i would recommend i
would ask that we i t i t l this at this
time is there a second
uh representation
uh sato uh uh recommends uh second on on
10 15. representative moffat do you have
sure mr uh briefly there's just uh
pieces of the
language here that just isn't ready to
move forward
any further discussion from the second
julius
okay uh from the committee is there any
further discussion on on 10 15.
i'm trying to represent cardelli
thank you
um
this is my bill um i'm the prime sponsor
so uh i
do not agree with the itl motion i had a
amendment ready
um
that i think addressed some concerns
including uh
more definition as to activities which
would not require activity notice
such as
assemblies and guest lectures and so
forth
i think that in my view this
goes to putting parents
in control of their children's education
which is a large issue around the
country
i think that parents
should have the right
to
both know what's going on in the
classroom and to um remove their
children from
areas or lessons that
they do not believe
comply with their
family values
so i think it is
needed legislation
and i'd like to speak in regard to this
bill
yes i agree that parents need to know
what's going on in their classrooms and
i think there's processes in place where
that is that opportunity is afforded
my primary reason for
objecting to this bill
is that
the teachable moment is critical in the
classroom
what's happening in ukraine today
if we had to wait two weeks to discuss
this
would be horrible
to have to hold off
and you can have teachable moments when
the the instructor asks we had that
wonderful teacher that was here that
taught social studies you don't have to
be imparting your opinion you can have
shared inquiry where the opinion is
bounced back and forth between the kids
in the room
and
and i think that
the the end result is we have a open
situation in our schools but you look at
so many issues that are going on right
now you can't wait for the teachable
moment when 9 11 occurred
you've got to do it then you can't wait
for the teachable moment when i remember
what happened at kent state you can't
wait for the teachable moment
when martin luther king was shot and i
can remember that it's etched in my head
in in my life um you can't wait for a
teachable moment when the volcano where
i was in alaska went off on mount
augustine the day of it and kids wanted
to talk about that area of education you
don't have two weeks
the the law that we have right now is
very specific and saying you have to
have two weeks notice
for issues such as sexual education it
was clearly stated
now this is now changing it so that you
need two weeks notice for just about
everything you're doing in the classroom
teachable moment for me when i was a
principal and the kid was sent down the
office for discipline i didn't expel
them
i talked i took that moment as a
teachable moment to try to steer a new
path
and without
throttling the child so that you know
you're destroying uh all interest in
school
do the same thing with my three-year-old
grandchildren child right now there's
teachable moment one after another and
it comes every other minute
so
that's what we have to do as teachers as
well
and so
there's where i am and that's why i am
going to vote in support of the motion
thank you
represent woodcock
thank you chairman i would concur with
your your your comments and also say
this would play havoc the social studies
education across the state
thank you
further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
this is house bill 1015 relative to
school district policies regarding
objectionable material the motion on the
table is itl
representative cordelli no
representative litchfield is yes
representative baum
president of lakes
yes
or sam moffatt
yes represent hobson
yes
does it have ford
yes i'm sony
yes represent nelson
from sam luno yes represent waltz yes
representative cornell yes
tanner yes representative ellison
represent mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes so the motion of
itl carries 18 to one
is there any objection to consent no
thank you is there a report for me
um
see that that report would be made my uh
representative moffat you know just for
the whole committee
there's no minority report yeah i i
don't believe you want to do that do you
you wouldn't do that it's on consent not
in consent so
good we're good to go there um
uh
representative cordelli do you have a
motion
i do mr chairman uh and that motion is
itl
is there a second on itl on this
represent mullen makes the second
so we have a motion to itl 1169 coming
from representative cordelli and second
by representative mullen represent
cordelia do you care to speak to your
motion
uh briefly mr chairman um
i certainly agree with
the
basically i think
part of the intent of this bill in terms
of
allowing the public
time to comment during board meetings i
think that that is an issue
i think it's an issue that public
comment often is held to the end of the
meeting so it's
after
issues that the public might want to
comment on has have already been
addressed
but i think this bill
takes it a step or two too far in terms
of
requiring
references to statutes or rules
when there is a question from the public
i i think it goes to
too far
generally and
might be better addressed in other
legislation
representative mullen
i agree with representative cordelli
that there are sections of the bill that
goes too far and also that there's never
a substitute for good communication
further discussion from members of the
committee
not seeing any madam clerk are you ready
take your time thank you sometimes
representative shaw would tell us to
stop
and she would say let me catch up and so
you have that thank you
house bill 1169 relative to public
comment inquiry during school board
meetings the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes representative lakers yes represent
moffat
yes represent hobson yes represent sodie
yes
represent ford yes
or sam nelson yes
represent luno
yes
represent waltz yes
representative cornell yes
representative tiener yes
representative ellison yes
represent mullen yes
or sam woodcock yeah
represent porter
rosetta
yes
and chairman ladd yes
so this motion carries 19 to zero
any objections to the consent calendar
thank you
uh the uh upcoming next bill is uh
do you have the amendment
okay so we're going to jump over uh 1137
as uh representative cordelli does have
an amendment and it's waiting for us
upstairs so he'll bring that down
and so we'll jump past that right now
and go to
uh hb 1295 requiring reports concerning
school policies and classroom recordings
and in classroom
observers
and or on and in classroom observers
uh representative uh moffat do you have
a motion
uh sure mr chair i'd like to move otp
is there a second
representation hi second thank you uh
representative would you like to speak
to your motion please
yeah thank you mr you'll recall
hopefully uh
the uh
when i introduced the spell explained
it's a very uh as i said very short very
simple and hopefully very sweet
there's no policy mandate there's no
spending requirement
and then it's modeled on
what many of us think is a very
successful gifted student
bill which we passed last year which is
not a lot
from the gifted bill um i'm already
hearing we're already hearing that all
over the state there are conversations
and discussions about uh
looking at
how to better identify and serve gifted
students and that was the intent of that
bill was to just
have districts required to have a
discussion and submit a report on what
they do or don't do
so this is the same thing
in
we see especially post covert a need to
have some local discussion on audio
visual recording policies
because during covert when covert is
still going on there is uh
there were
a lot there was a lot of remote learning
there was hybrid learning and
which was a new world i don't know if it
was a brave new world but
uh
there were a lot of uh questions that
did come up around the state about you
know who could watch a hybrid class or a
remote class could it be recorded
uh obviously so from our own experiences
this committee had remote hearings last
year
uh we had policies about uh who could be
there who could listen uh you know
we had dogs that were there which we
became rather fond of as as uh as time
went on
but uh
those uncharted waters so the focus is
of this measure is simply to
and several of us have talked to several
people at doe about this
and they
saw her interest in merit and doing the
same thing here as they did with gifted
which would be to have a
best practices folder so to speak
so that
some definition could be achieved in
terms of uh
recording policies for example we're
being youtube now i think when i
introduced a bill i pointed that out
uh so
my words in the words
of all of us
are recorded
forever i guess i don't know how long
youtube lasts
so
uh and for youngsters um
when we were in a covid hybrid remote
situation and i think representative
during the hearing represent nelson
expressed concern about you know
possible special ed
situations where where there might be
some unique
um
circumstances so um
that's it uh you know some privacy
issues that are part of this as well
and the second part of this the smaller
part had to do with classroom recordings
uh and again if you recall i talked
about that uh again having been in the
college classrooms you know most
professors have syllabi that talk about
recording procedures you know i know we
uh
some class especially like in the
medical field with his lectures i know
students like to record the lectures
now in the high school level uh
again most a lot of us have been in the
classroom when i was in the classroom
these things weren't
ubiquitous but they are now and i think
a lot of teachers have policies that you
can't you you pull out a cell phone uh
again this is not about any specific
policy we don't want to get in the weeds
but uh these are areas that
uh some schools i think are have
wonderful police policies uh developed
and uh
be value in sharing those
and you know transparency issues um the
the classroom visitation piece uh i i
think i want to thank almost every if
not every school already has a policy in
terms of who can visit a classroom even
you know during covert that was
during hybrid classes that was an issue
because
uh
you know some parents
wanted to
you know help their youngster out by
especially the youngster was sick if it
was an option to go in and get material
or record classes anyway these these are
things that
uh
i i think some of us think just need
attention so
it's just a best practices folder submit
a report
you can just send an email and uh we've
talked to doe about it so anyway thank
you thank you very much uh represent
like us do you have uh
anything to add um it it doesn't cost
anything just like the other didn't cost
anything it doesn't force them to do
anything other than file a report but
what it hopefully will do will cause
them to think about do we have a policy
and maybe should we have a policy it
doesn't even force them to have one
just to state what if any it is but the
hope is that they will develop one if
they don't just because it draws it to
their attention
thank you very much i'm going to take a
moment here and um
ask that the school boards is willing to
come up and and take a couple questions
for myself
um
technical support
we oftentimes do this with specialists
that come to our exec sessions
uh becky thank you for coming
can you tell me what's the process that
the school boards association has in
terms of
policies in regard to matters which are
in this bill as far as
getting this information out to various
school districts and boards
thanks so much for the question for the
record becky wilson director of
governmental relations for new hampshire
school boards association
short short girl problems over here
we have about a dozen policies sample
policies that our member districts have
access to that reference
videoing recording surveillance
the difference between
student recordings
and recordings that are being used for
school purposes such as teacher
evaluation potentially
extracurriculars like drama
clubs or performances recordings of
speakers so there are a number of
policies that districts have access to
that school boards can then put into
place some are recommended policies some
are required policies
in terms of the visitor
policy we also do have a recommended
visitor policy sample policy that
districts can adopt um that all of the
policies we ask districts to take their
own lens and look at those policies and
really adapt them to meet the needs of
their individual school boards but we do
have a number of different policies
around both
video and audio recordings as well as
visitation thank you very much and i'll
ask
one more question here and then opening
up if others have same
requests
when i looked at the school boards
association site the other evening i
noticed that there's three categories of
of how you identify them as required or
you know might be nice to have or and
another category statutory requirement
are any of the uh policies which you
have that
in respect to this particular bill
statutory requirements
there are some that are required under
student privacy specifically when house
bill 1558 passed a number of years ago
in terms of
student data privacy and technology
privacy a lot of the surveillance
that school districts are using for
safety for student safety
would kind of overcross with that
particular
policy in terms of required student
privacy data privacy so there are some
surveillance
policies that districts must have in
terms of how they're keeping their
surveillance video and recordings
how they are being used how they cannot
be used in those types of issues
can i i just said one more in regard to
that statutory is there anything
statutorily
established i could look through statute
i guess but maybe you have better handle
on than i
regarding security in buildings
whether or not video is required for
security yeah anything that's that
choice says you you need to have cameras
on the playgrounds play yards in the
hallways etc
it's not required for you to have
surveillance video
on school district grounds
however is recommended and those
policies are recommended there is a
different set of policies for
transportation that are required in
terms of how the surveillance on buses
and things like that can be used and
what those pieces are required in fact i
believe that school buses are the only
place that video and audio
are required as opposed to just the
video surveillance is that required and
statutory required or just plain
required
from your policy perspective i would
have to
double check on that but i believe
they're just recommended i don't believe
they are required
maybe the doe would have some answers in
that one as well the doe was here
earlier i'm not sure where they've
oh
okay okay thank you you'll have to find
a new title for her today but she's back
there apparently she's back in the cheap
seat she just went down to lieutenant
colonel there you go
she can tell you exactly which policies
are required by statute and which are
just recommended
representative do you have any questions
yes yes thank you very much mr chair and
thanks becky for joining us this morning
thanks for having me on the policies
that um that that the chair was just
asking you about particularly the the
policies that are required under statute
um with respect to um video and audio
uh capture
are any of those do any of those
policies
also
also apply to
non-public schools that provide
education services to public school to
school districts for example a school
like pinkerton
that's a very good question
representative thank you for asking it i
would have to double check because
school boards association really doesn't
represent
non-public
school boards or any i would have to
double check and see which ones are
applicable i would imagine if the school
district is contracting with another
non-public program or another public
academy for example that those would
need to meet the same requirements as
the local school district
you're welcome yes represent woodcock
and then represent lakes
thank you chairman good morning good
morning uh
just a quick question about uh
your record-keeping association you
folks uh track
each school system and what which
particular policies they
have
from you or have used or have
like a catalog
so a good man would be confused if i
asked you about apop
hello audrey if i asked if i asked you
about a policy uh on x you could tell me
these 400 schools have it thank you for
the question um because not every school
board is a member of our association we
don't track specifically which boards
have adopted which sample policies from
our policy manual or suggested sample
policies
because we offer them as sample policies
and we are hoping that each district is
really modifying them to meet their
individual district need we're not
keeping track of how many people uh how
many boards for example have adopted x
policy we do offer a service to
districts where we will do a policy
review of all of a district's policies
or school boards policies to see if that
up to date if they're meeting all the
required policies
how many recommended policies they've
taken so we have a sort of a
you know bird's eye view of what
districts have but we are not keeping
track of individual policies for each
district thank you so much thank you
chairman you're welcome further question
represent like us
i have a couple related i just had one
but you made me think of another one
um the one is
so if a
school board
with this
bill were to realize that oh we don't
have a policy on x
they would easily be able to then
get if they said oh maybe we should do
that it would be an easy thing to
download a sample policy from you guys
is that
true
yeah policy policy services are
available to all of our member districts
so as if they were a member of our
association then yes they could work
with us to develop a policy or use our
sample policy and adapt it to what's
appropriate for their district
okay and if they weren't they would just
maybe ask another school district or
would it okay yes i mean it's
most district policies are available
online for school districts to community
members or parents or whoever wants to
look at policies so it's pretty
accessible to most people at this point
for people for districts to get their
hands on policies yes thank you very
much thank you are there further
questions from yes representative tanner
thank you um would you consider that the
policies that you provide
would be best practices policies because
they have been legally
perused and
present
the best opportunity for school
districts
thank you for the question we do have a
policy attorney specifically who looks
at all of our sample policies and
develops those in accordance with
whatever is the current statute and the
current requirements we do ask every
member district to work with their own
legal counsel
when they're looking at policies because
not every district is the same and we
want to be sure that they're really
making a policy that's going to be
reasonable and appropriate for their
individual district but yes we work very
hard to make sure that all of our sample
policies are up to date and they get
updated every year after the legislative
session is done
follow up on that yes
so
they would also be available to the
department of education
to
publish and send out to schools if they
so wish right rather than perhaps having
each district report to the department
of education thank you for the question
i would leave that up to the department
of whether or not that's something that
they would want to
partake in in terms of working with the
school board's association on individual
policies that's really something the
department would have to weigh in on
thank you welcome further question
represent luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much for uh for taking another
question becky um what um what your
your answer to representative tanner's
question um
sort of piqued
an interest
in what this bill is all about and and
the the um
representative moffat refers to this
bill as being about the department
collecting of having a folder of best
practices
with respect to
to observer policies and audio video
streaming and recording policies
and given what you just said about how
the school board association develops
model policies that are that are
that are developed with them
by an attorney
but then recommend
each school district to consult with
their own attorney
on um on the unique needs
characteristics and and obviously
um
you know their own their own school
board attorney is the one that
represents the school board uh if uh if
this is ever ever put to a challenge
that um would would would this folder
really truly be a best practices folder
or would it really be a collection of
policies that uh that have now been
passed by various school boards may
differ by school board depending upon
what their unique circumstances are and
what their own school board attorney
may recommend
thank you for the question
collecting any kind of copies of
policies or things like that i
i don't know who would vet what is
considered a best practice policy versus
what is collecting the policies that
currently exist um you know there's
certainly ways to make sure that every
policy meets whatever is the
requirements if there is a particular
requirement for a certain policy to
ensure that your policy aligns with
what's required
whether or not it's considered best
practice
i'm not sure who would be making that
determination or what the definition of
that would be specific to surveillance
and video
policies or classroom visitation
quick follow-up mr chair yes um so would
a
what a what a policy for um
for
observer policies audio video streaming
recording policies that are adopted in
let's say salem
the um the ideal
um for um
for let's say newport
thank you for the question i every
district is individual and i believe
that it's really up to the district to
ensure that whatever policies they're
putting in place are going to work for
their
particular district and their particular
needs um
what's best for one district is not
necessarily going to be best for every
district it's quite different if you
have you know 10 buildings in your
district versus a one k to two school or
something i mean there's very different
uh reasons to have
different policies for different
districts and that's why we do not
just hand out cookie cutter policies and
say you know just fill in these blanks
we're expecting that districts are
working with their own school boards to
develop policies that are going to work
for their individual needs
thank you mr chair um thanks for taking
my question uh ms wilson
so in these policies that you have this
this particular bill deals with
classroom recordings and in classroom
observers
do any of the policies that you have
about classroom recordings also
take into consideration in classroom
observers or
do you have separate policies for those
two aspects of eyes in the classroom
thank you for the question we have
separate policies
in fact even the videoing and the
recording policies are dif there's a
number of different ones there's one
specifically for
surveillance for safety purposes there's
a separate
aspect of that that is for if teachers
are using recordings in the classroom
for their own professional development
there's aspects of recording by students
that's in the student handbook that's
recommended to go into student handbooks
about what students can
cannot record or what purposes they can
and cannot record
you know district policy speaks
specifically about using district
equipment to record versus using
personal equipment
those are all very separate from
visitation or observation
and again i think there is also a
difference between visiting a classroom
and having someone come in to observe a
classroom with a particular purpose
there's a there are also very different
reasons for those kinds of visitations
and those are spelled out in different
policies it's
you know school visitors is quite
different than an outside person who's
coming in to observe for a particular
purpose perhaps for a teacher who's
going through a higher ed program and
they need to be observed etc those are
very different purposes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um do you encourage
school districts to um
disclose those policies in the
appropriate cases in other words if
someone comes in and they're videotaping
or
you know just like here it's announced
when the videotaping is begin so
everybody's aware that they're being
videotaped
do you encourage those
policies to be
uh you know either written or spoken to
the people that they affect thank you
for the question
depending on the purpose of the
observation or the visit those policies
would absolutely be disclosed to the
person that's coming in um you know
certainly classroom visitors there's a
procedure that needs to be in place in
every building or in every classroom and
every school that that is made aware to
people who are coming in to visit the
school
if people are coming in to observe then
yes they would need to
be given that policy or at least be made
aware of whatever the policy is in terms
of recordings
there are references to specific
recording
policies in the student handbook excuse
me that students and parents sign off on
every year
there's also a video release that
parents sign every single year either
they allow their child to be videoed or
not and released that happens every
single year so those are all part of
making sure that people are aware of the
purposes of why things are
recorded or videotaped and how they will
be used and parents have the right to
opt their child out of that
do you know if um and i'm it's not
necessarily your purview so you may not
know but
do do the charter schools um
that are also public schools uh do you
know if they
also have policies written and and um
encouraged to you know have in student
handbooks and that sort of thing
thank you for the question i don't know
specifically what charter schools are
required to have in terms of their
student handbooks or things like that
that's a question for the department
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you becky
for taking this
this bill requires um
school districts to
submit a report to the department of
education concerning the policy are
there other policies that you know of
that are requi it's a requirement that
school districts submit them to the
department of education
thank you for the question i do know
last year when they passed the bill in
this committee in terms of required
they're not required policies but that
if you had a policy regarding your
programming for gifted students that
that would be sent to the department and
the department would hold those in a
folder at the department
there aren't safety policies and safety
plans and things like that that need to
be filed with the department but they
are not specific policies to my
knowledge but again that would be a
question for the department
further questions representative wood
thank you it's for
it's not for ms wilson for
representative wafflet i'll
oh wait
thank you
happy to help
um just a question of representative
moffat
looking back on the notes of january
27th when you made the initial
presentation
and you described it then as you did
today mike that this is a best practice
similar to the gift and talented one
that you passed before but as i listen
to the discussion today
it doesn't appear to be any best
practice scenario this is just a
seminar policy which could be
it has no value it doesn't have it
doesn't have the same
incentive for schools to go look at this
where they
appreciate public schools because they
can already get the policies through the
school board or they already have one
so i don't understand the the
connection between best practice and
just submitting a policy to a file where
there's they're all pretty much
standardized
sure that's a great question and uh
representative asked a good question too
uh best practices i use that term on the
27th i guess and today uh use it with a
gifted bill but as becky pointed out uh
in response to uh representative luna's
question it's it's
the term best practices maybe i
shouldn't use that today it's a just a
centralized policy
uh
folder if you will for people to
see what other districts are doing and
what's what might work for them so yeah
best practices uh
is not part of the language of the
statute and
you know it probably doesn't
i probably
didn't need to use best practices if it
confused anybody yeah it's a policy
folder not a best practices folder
thank you mr chair
uh having worked for the department of
education for 41 years
i i have yet to see
a best practice
folder or policy folder which had any
significant impact on education in the
state
i think as a committee we need to be
very very careful and this comes up from
time to time
that well let's go ahead and try this
this won't hurt so let's see if it will
work and i think we we add those things
in to the department of ed it's just
another thing there which in it
ultimately doesn't work so i'll be
voting against the motion
we're okay here
we're here
testing
we're good here
oh i just headed up
this one seems to be working
it's it's a sign
so i have two observations one is
representative lycus uh lucas i'm going
to get this right said that this doesn't
cost anything that's just wrong it costs
every school district money to produce
these reports and to say it doesn't cost
anything just because it's not a line
item thing it is costing districts money
and we need to be aware that every time
we do one of these from on high kind of
policies the second observation i have
is that i can't understand why we're
doing this it's not like people are
going to be coming and pulling those
folders and looking at them other than
perhaps the department of education
which is trying to play big brother from
my point of view they want to know what
people are doing so they can try and
regulate it we are all about local
control if we're about local control why
are we doing this why are we collecting
these policies why are we playing big
brother and frankly why this may be
slightly intimidating about what is our
policy what do we want to tell the state
you know i don't think we should be
playing local control i don't think we
should be putting these kinds of
requirements on a district just for the
sake of having these requirements i
think we ought to think long and hard
before we impose these kinds of
things it sure does
uh thank you mr uh sure uh just on the
on the money issue i do agree with
representative leckus uh
in the in terms of
reports or policies i think most schools
already have a wait till representative
wales
oh it was represented woodcock
okay blame it on your neighbor huh
go ahead representative i want to make
sure episodes could hear me trying to
answer her question um
yes uh the the part of this about
classroom visitations for example i
think most if not all districts have
something in place if there's some that
don't then this is a chance for them to
pay some attention to it in terms of
money i agree with representative lekkis
uh i think this would most cases involve
an administrative assistant sending an
email and an attachment to doe uh it
would take a minute i think in most
cases as i as many of us see that and i
also wanted to just respond a little bit
to representative allison um becky in
terms of policies going to doa becky
wilson
cited a couple other examples for
example safety protocols you know does
asking for reports on a number of things
for followers if you will she cited
safety protocols i think there's value
to those you know like you're saying
that you didn't see the value in
in collecting such things you know
obviously i i do
um so i just wanted to respond to that
as well thank you representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions and comments uh
representative moffitt
so were you surprised as i was surprised
to listen to the
list of subcategories of recordings and
just how many aspects of recording
in a classroom there are
sure in fact um
that's if i can say this uh
some of you that's the beauty of the
measure like this
is that uh just this taken a little bit
longer than maybe we thought it would
but all the
discus the points and discussion that's
flowing from this
uh proposed measure
um in terms of what you just mentioned
uh being surprised
being surprised at what's out there
again
please this is not a policy mandate
that's what kind of slowed down the
gifted bill for a while because people
were saying what about this or about
that what about this one about that what
about surveillance about that that's not
the intent of this bill again uh the
bill is intended to collect data and
encourage districts to have in some
cases overdue discussions particularly
post covent again very simple and so i i
don't want to
get down in the weeds that's not the
intent
follow up mr chair yeah i was just as i
listened to
ms wilson discuss it it in my own mind
went from one report to two
one report being on recordings and a
second report
on ins in classroom observers
and it went from what was being
described as
you know a super easy 30-second thing
to a report out on
eight different aspects of recording in
a classroom whether it's students
recording teachers recording
the teacher being recorded student
privacy issues uh
so i mean obviously miss wilson had the
list
of things so i was surprised at that it
seems that it's much more involved
than i had
initially read into the bill and in your
gifted and talented uh bill i'm looking
at it there's a section uh three that
says that the department shall develop a
standardized format for submission
uh
that and reassess it each year and and
whatever was it your intention that the
department
developed some sort of a format for this
report as well
if i may respond mr chair yeah sure
uh
yes uh the department you mentioned the
gift of bill the department uh we met
with them they actually did
develop a format
the d.o.e dead which they promulgated
and sent out so that the districts would
have a way to respond
and you make a good point
in that as i said i think with the
visitation perceive policies that those
probably in place and fairly easy to
respond to but you're right uh
because
in the audio visual recording domain
it's a new and i think a needed area
that needs
discussion and attention
uh that could take a
considerable time depends on the
district and whoever is there at the
district
if if they end up spending um
you know various amounts of time on it
that it's good obviously it shows us a
need to spend some time uh and get some
definition uh locally on uh what their
policies are and to and to be asked or
required to submit a report to doe
provides the impetus for this discussion
locally that yeah i
think needs to happen
one one more follow-up okay just one
more go ahead i promise um so
representative
the doe involvement in
in uh developing the report format is
not in this bill it was in the gifted
and talented bill but it's not in this
bill was that your intention is there a
reason why it's not in the bill
sure good question and uh
several of us did meet with several
folks at doe and they like the idea of
this and i guess it's implied that doe
would without getting too detailed and
prescriptive and how they respond to the
statute i i'm sure they would
similarly to the gifted bill
provide some guidance in in terms of how
to submit the
data or the report well it's in statute
in the gifted
bill correct
i'm going to take a few moments to just
give a couple options i got to go on at
a teleconference meeting at 11 o'clock
uh regarding higher ed
uh i i i asked a question that
why is this specific to in classroom
uh when in fact
the whole school is a classroom
from the cafeteria to the
pe area the multi-purpose room to the
music room to the art facilities it's
all classroom including
small conference rooms which are used
for supplemental education or remedial
education what have you we use every
space
but my concern that you know
i could understand gathering this
information if it were for a specific
purpose and the specific purpose would
i'd love to see
deals with emergency management planning
which we now know we have to submit this
information directly to homeland
security
then over to the department of education
we dealt with that already this year
i'd love to know if i'd really not love
to know but i appreciate knowing if the
we have that streaming capability
available
in
throughout our schools
which then it can be also seen on the
responder on their screen in their
vehicle whether it be the sheriff the
police state troopers police etc what's
going on in the school in case of
some kind of an issue within the school
i see a real positive behind that and
the rationale for that
um
so but as far as in classroom itself
i know we need to have policies and how
we do
everything in regard to education it's
it's just the way we live
but
it's
to me curriculum and instruction becomes
a local responsibility
and i don't see why this can't be
handled on the local level that's where
where i am
so i got to leave right now i'm going to
hand this over to represent cordelia
i've got to get on the phone in the
other room i'll be right back
when it comes time to any voting or et
cetera
thank you
representative luno thank you very much
mr chair and um
and you know i think that obviously
we're having uh i think quite an
in-depth discussion and uh with with
with
also with technical support from school
board
association and maybe from the
department of ed but oh yeah um
so i think there's i think there's a lot
of questions um with respect to
to to this
i know i would like to learn um maybe
more about
from the department how
how school districts would uh would
would be able to access this um this
best practices folder so that they could
take advantage of the information there
and and and how the department is going
to make that available that data
available to um to school districts um
in a useful productive um
manner
that
that that also identifies maybe why
certain school districts do it one way
and other school districts do another
way for some of the reasons why
that that ms wilson um brought up
and um
and you know i'd also like to
maybe understand a little bit more from
the department's perspective
uh what their costs of of doing this
operation you know
to make that data available
would be
there's obviously local costs of
compiling um uh data and sending it to
the uh to the department then there's
the department's data in collecting this
i mean the department's costs and
collecting this data from
what
220 um
schools
and um and and and processing that
and then and then finally i think from
the
from a
school's you know perspective
the um uh
and this gets to i think to chair lad's
recent comment that that schools have
policies for everything well they don't
necessarily need policies for everything
they need policies they require policies
that we require in statute those are the
required uh policies
uh policies that they adopt beyond that
are are because they're
the school board and the members of the
community
want to be able to hold the school
district uh accountable to making sure
that they follow those policies and
and that's very likely why uh while a
lot of policies that ms wilson was
talking about and especially the
policies with respect to audio video
streaming and recording
and in classroom
where they're not required have been
adopted by
by school districts so um
so i i guess i you know would it be
possible to hear from the the department
with respect to what their plans are
uh and would be with this and how this
is going to be valuable to
schools would attorney fenton
care to provide any technical support on
this
legislation
well you could you could get a promotion
from our current chair
hope springs
field a field field promotion there you
go
always hope so um
from the department's perspective and my
understanding of the testimony and the
intent from the sponsor
what is before this committee is very
similar to the legislation that was
brought forward last session
in regards to gifted and talented
policies and my understanding is that
the department has implemented that
legislation um by creating it was an
electronic folder i know last session
there was a lot of debate as to whether
or not it would be an actual
paper folder or it would be electronic
and i think there was an amendment in
the senate to make um
and i know in speaking with
the commissioner the intent and the
thought was
we'll have it
on our website available for
for public inspection and consumption to
just go and look at those policies and
that was the discussion and the intent
and to facilitate that my understanding
is that the department i know met with
representative moffitt to create a form
to streamline that so that there would
be that consistency across the board
because i know some of the discussion
was you will have some discrepancies or
inconsistencies from one district to
another and so i think to just
facilitate ease of readership
um
a form was developed and i would
anticipate the department would take a
similar approach if this bill were were
to be passed by this legislative body
in terms of the cost
as this
as this committee well knows there are
some bills that come forward which would
add a considerable cost
to the department we need new staff
etc
it is not
based on the plane reading of this this
is a bill that similar to last year's
bill can be incorporated with the state
we can create that form as we did last
time and put it up on our website for
public consumption and so we do not
anticipate that there would be a
significant
cost associated with it but again that's
from the department's perspective i am
not speaking on behalf of the districts
which you also alluded to we're not in a
position to talk about that particular
cost
uh representative tanner
you know as i'm i'm thinking about this
um and particularly with what uh
representative lad chair lad spoke about
how
the whole school's a classroom and then
we talked about the different types of
of video that's been taken
i'm not sure we want
streaming video of schools
being the public
for security purposes i'm sure homeland
security would have some input on
perhaps the policies but once you
establish the policies it may give
people who wanted to use
videotapes
for not particularly great reasons
um
access uh to information that they
shouldn't have
um i see
you know when i asked the school boards
association about um
do they post the the policies
uh certainly here we hear you know okay
you're being recorded now um we don't
know the policies other than it's going
to be on youtube uh representative
moffat doesn't even know how long
in perpetuity
the youtube lasts neither do i right um
and we don't know how those
uh
videotapes can be used um
for against us i guess is is probably
um or even to come in and
take over this building for that matter
so um i think it's this although this
sounds really simple you know really
easy really like this is a good thing
and it's going to spark good things i
think it already has sparked good things
probably from people listening in and
and and that sort of thing i don't i
think we need to take a step back i
really do i think we need to
think about the ramifications and
security purposes
in uh
in schools um
we're videotapes you know and security
tapes and
all kinds of tapes have been you know
video has been taken so
um
i don't know if that's a question to you
or just it's a comment in my mind about
do you see
probably from your legal standpoint
how this might
mushroom into something more than what
we really want it to be and maybe needs
further study
so as an initial matter
i
in anticipation of your question opened
up my book to 194b uh
charter schools and i am disappointed
that it has nothing to do with charter
schools so i i was trying to be there
with you and i i
[Laughter]
so
i think any bill that is passed any bill
that is reviewed and this committee
knows this better than i do could have
potential um
unintended consequences right
i think that
this is obviously an area of of great
concern as to whether or not
this bill should be studied further
that's not for me to decide that's for
this body to decide um
i think that
on on its face
the way it is currently written
it is
it
it is a bill
that the department can easily implement
the implications of that
go beyond the plain language
discuss previously
the law 194b explicitly states
that and i forget the provision that i
sent you the other day but it does say
in here in two places
that unless stated in other areas of the
law
that the charter school bill uh charter
school law rather the chapter is very
narrowly tailored
so the way i read this
in
in context with 194b
is that unless it explicitly states this
is to apply to charter schools
it would not just
so happens i have an amendment for that
thank you
yes i'd like to make a motion on an
amendment
okay we have
an emotion on the floor we have
additional questions of the department
if we could take care of that first you
may
uh representative porter
thank you mr chair i'm not exactly sure
if this is for you
or if it's for representative moffat
um but i'm i'm questioning why i and i i
apologize because i was not here the day
of the hearing on this bill so i didn't
have the benefit of hearing everything
that was said then
but i'm wondering why we are doing this
and
instead of just saying
school districts shall develop a policy
dealing with
this
and let it happen the way it had all the
other policies happened by the school
boards association and that sort of
thing why are we getting
this the department of education
to collect these policies i
it seems so out of place
and would we be starting a process where
um
the department of education now has to
start collecting the policies of
playground use or bus
procedures or all these other ish areas
where schools have policies
i guess am i making sense why are we
making the department of education even
be a conduit for this
and i'm not sure if that's
probably not for you representative
moffat's not listening so maybe you're
the one that's going to need to answer
it
i don't know represent
do you have a response attorney fenton
um i i do and i understand your question
in large part i will refer to the
sponsor of this bill but my
understanding and i don't want to speak
for you obviously but my understanding
was there was a thought in in the bill
that was passed last year is related to
gifted and talented students was to have
not a clearing house but a centralized
location is probably the better term a
centralized location where districts
could access
information as to how other districts
are handling the situation and i think
that was the intent
on this bill as well same idea same
concept different topic but again i will
i will refer to representative moffat on
that
uh if i may
yes attorney fenton uh described that
very well and and your question about
you know playground policies i mean that
that's a fair question too
um the reason
that
i or the folks at sport are gifted or
this bill
wanted it to come through this process
is that the imprimatur of legislative
action of statutory action matter
matters uh we think
the commission can send a memo out
and ask for
uh policies and that's
just not it doesn't have the gravitas or
the import that that uh
the imprimatur of legislative action has
because this is i obviously think this
is really important and uh and this
legislative
action uh underscores the importance of
it
thank you so yeah i understand that but
i don't understand why we're not you
should be awesome
is this attorney fenton i would like to
finish up with the questions to attorney
fenton first
uh representative mullen
thank you representative cordelian thank
you for taking my question diana
so 189 29b
which is the gifted and talented statute
that was added last year
has three distinct sections
the first is a definition of gifted and
talented should this bill be identical
to that bill perhaps a a definition of
what in classroom
recordings or observers are
might have appeared there the second is
the second session roman two is the
requirement to file the report
and then roman three is the uh
directive to the department of education
that says that they will develop the
format
my question to you is this
is that gifted and talented bill as a
model
more
directive
than the bill that we have in front of
us there is no definition there is no
directive to the department of ed to
develop the format we keep comparing the
two bills but when i look at 189 29b
i see something very different than
what's in front of us in house bill 1295
and
i'm wondering what your take is on that
i think that's thank you for the
question it's a very astute observation
and
um
the department will respond to what is
passed and what is printed and so if
that is the intent of this body to have
it be similar um in the ways that we
have described then it would certainly
behoove this committee to structure it
in a similar manner
um
so yes i think that would be that would
be helpful in terms of the directive to
the department as to what the
expectation is
thank you any further questions for
attorney fenton um representative nelson
thank you mr chairman i'm curious as to
how much data
your department collects it seems like
in this whole place everybody's
collecting something and they got a book
this thing
how much types of data do they collect
and you know this is this just a drop of
the bucket
uh
thank you for the question
the department
the department does collect
a significant amount of of information
um
[Music]
i joked recently with commissioner
edelblut and he said sometimes it's just
bureaucrats being bureaucrats
and you know
acting bureaucratically i think was his
term and collecting information and so i
think you know when we looked at the
bill that representative moffat brought
up uh last session
um and we appreciate his openness to
modifying his bill last session there
was a concern that it would just become
another
paper and a folder um and so i think
when we pivoted a little bit
and revamped it to put it in a set
format working closely with the
department to create this form and put
it on the on the website so that it
would have more utilitarian purposes
it became more accessible for people and
it and it was less about the department
just collecting
more information in more paper um that
is always a concern of the departments
and so
we successfully i think last year's
session taught certainly me in the
department that we were able to work and
to achieve the representatives goals and
to cut back on that
collection piece just for collecting
purposes
but yes
in a short answer yes the department
collects
a lot of information
and it's all passed statutorily
were there any further questions i
thought i saw another hand
uh not seen any thank you
um
miss fenton it's hard to know what to
call me i know
i can tell you as a former prosecutor i
have been called a lot worse so i i
appreciate it if we called her
ambassador we might have to send her
over to the ukraine
yes
representative hopson
thank you mr chair um
i believe i might have been out the week
that this bill was presented and
i
i'm going back and forth on this bill
but i
something has
i wanted to present to the committee
it's kind of made its way to my head
today
in this air in this era of uh
recordings and remote
um
i have really benefited from
the house education committee receptacle
for
videos and you know in preparing
testimony for bills
going back you know i could look at a
bill today and say oh my gosh i don't
remember anything about that bill i go
back to the recording
and i and i listen to it and i am
brought right back to that day and my
feelings and my thoughts on the bill
i don't think we've talked about that
here today and the difference between
watching a recording in a classroom as a
student
and being in a zoom class
to me those are completely different um
i can watch the recording when it when
it makes sense for me when i can hear it
and absorb it versus being in a zoom
and worrying about what you know susie
is saying and you know the phone's
ringing and my kids need food or
whatever
um so i that's
as a as a just a receptacle and again
i'm
i don't want to profess to know all the
things that this bill covers but i think
it's important to
think about it from that aspect and some
of the bills that we're listening to
for remote
um that's all i wanted to say thank you
um
representative lagas excuse me
representative porter you i think you
had a question that you wanted to uh
submit to
representative moffat
yes thank you for remembering mr chair
and guess what the question that i had
was why is this going to the department
of education why are we setting
school districts up for being watched
over so carefully by the department of
education when we could just
put in statute that
districts shall develop a policy having
to do with these things and then allow
them to do it
it's in statute um the school boards
association has their lawyers that would
help them it would get done because it
would be required by statute but it
doesn't force the school districts to
submit these
reports to the department of education
to be overlooked and what's the next
thing they're going to have to send into
the department of education and the next
thing and the next thing and pretty soon
the department becomes the overseer of
all these individual policies from
individual districts
it feels
pardon my usage but it feels a little
bit like big brother to me we're setting
the department up to be watching over
very carefully every aspect of what goes
on in the local districts and maybe you
know maybe we want to do that but i
don't think we do
sure thanks for the comment i mentioned
earlier that uh the reason for
going this route through doe in the
legislative process as i said before um
is a way to uh
underscore the importance of this
evolving
issue with with technology and yeah i am
not big on reports uh unless unless
there are
ones that that you know uh
i think or we think make a difference i
think gifted definitely has made a
difference
every
all of us say no people are talking
about districts are talking about uh you
know developing gifted policies which is
the intent of that
um
i hear your point and i i would not want
to overburden them but i think there are
some things that are reasonable to
expect uh from the doe and from
districts and
uh
you know this is is is one of them
thank you very much mr chair um
do um and this is this is really a
question to you um mr chair do we know
if homeland security is weighed in on
on the framework and development of
audio video capture and dissemination
policies
and what sort of impact that could have
not just
on student safety
but uh but beyond that in terms of um um
and i'm forgetting the term that uh that
the homeland security
uh that the representative from homeland
security used here recently but um but
uh situational situational management
and things like that well on in regard
to the emergency response plans when we
had the 30 million dollars which we are
distributing the schools for security
measures
upgrading
we do know that we do have the streaming
available in some schools it's not all
schools
and cameras was one of the issues which
we were purchasing
and then of course looking at the
placement of cameras and in the entry
areas in the access and egress areas
but we do not have any policy that
requires these to be in place
um or for schools to have them so and we
don't have this information that's why i
was keenly interested if this was
applying to the whole school and whether
we could get information as a result of
something like this but i don't think
this is going to provide that to us in
that regard
so emergency management response
emergency response planning
is important and uh i feel that an issue
that we as need to be starting to talk
with the director over there homeland
with her over homeland security and with
the department of education
and just because we have these plans
identified in stash doesn't mean we have
it totally worked out yet we did do the
task forces and i i saw represent tanner
looking at that booklet the other day i
was doing the same thing
and uh it doesn't mention you know in
the recommendations to the back for
legislative improvements and
recommendations i have not seen one that
recommends that we have the that
streaming video capability uh in all our
schools
something we may want to pursue so my my
concern mr chair is that if schools if
some schools um therefore need to make
uh make it publicly known
that uh
beyond the mere absence of a um that
would be a mistake if we did that navy
policy yeah that they made it known that
they don't have any recordings or
recording capabilities one of the
reasons why we've had difficulty at the
very start of this program
when director plummer at that time was
doing all the digitizing over there at
homeland security on the other side of
concord here is that school districts
were concerned about the confidentiality
of those plans which would be submitted
from the high school or the elementary
schools because it's all schools
what happens in the interim is this
going to be confidential by the time it
gets to homeland security so they were
questioning whether we should even do
that
it was after resolving some of those
things with the director and with the
commissioner at doe we were able to set
up a process in which that works and
right now the legislation which we just
addressed earlier this session we go
directly down to homeland security
and then they communicate with doe and
the oversight of the program this does
responsibility if you haven't done it mr
luno in your school then doe is going to
get on you get it into homeland security
we found that when we initially were
handing out that 30 million dollars a
number schools had not complied
because of the security issues that you
speak of
yeah representative moffatt
thank you miss sharon once again uh you
were out of the room uh attorney finn
did a great job i thought uh tying in
the intent of the bill and the president
of the bill that's my first point second
one is uh i i'm seeing us getting down
into the weeds again and this is what
slowed down the gifted bill which was
introduced a long time ago you know
folks are getting into what about this
or about that and that's not the intent
of that bill it was slowed down longer
than it needed to be i think
and it's and it's not the intent of this
spell i'm hearing you know uh you know
what about homeland security about all
these that's that's what should come out
of this if or when this moves forward
but that's
we don't i'm not looking to get into
those details now and finally
a procedural question mr chair i'm
looking at representative tanner's
amendment that she passed out which i i
think makes a lot of sense and
i like it and
i do want to say because this i'm sure
will come up
um
the wording of the present uh proposed
measure simply asked superintendents of
districts to to respond with the report
um
and i was kind of waiting for the
question what about broadening that and
the reason my answer would have been to
again to keep it uh simple
uh
because there are some ephemeral
questions about homeschoolers or some of
the new situations but i i really
like him and could and would support
representative tanner's amendment if we
get to that but procedurally to get to
that
we
we would need to
do otp and then otpa is that correct
okay all right uh that's my question
procedurally i i i could support her
amendment i i you know
i i've got a lot of questions on on
process we're talking about here if
we're trying to find out
and try to alert school districts that
we should have policies in place and i'm
sure they all do we've heard from the
new hampshire school boards association
there are boilerplate policies available
if we're trying to make get a collection
together here
sometimes i feel the legislature starts
stepping out of our territory into the
territory of the executive branch
and the departments an administrative
bulletin could easily go out to all the
schools addressing the issue of of this
issue of policy
make sure you have policy in place
i see this very narrow it's it's only in
classroom it's not the whole school i
see this i i just briefly read the
amendment here for the first time when i
see education service providers while
we're going well beyond the schoolhouse
now
and
it's it's
i'm trying to get in my head what is the
purpose of the whole thing here um
so um
so represent like us you have a question
i have some more comments discussion
um
the re i believe the reason it is just
classroom recordings is so that we don't
get into all of those issues of security
and homeland security and if we let the
public know what our policies are
regarding observing hallways and
everything we don't want to make those
public so this doesn't cover that this
is specifically about in classroom
recordings because some schools have
talked about putting out recordings in
all classrooms and some schools have
said they aren't going to do that and
and as far as money and that kind of
stuff
i believe the
superintendents and the
you know whoever would assistance and
whatever who would be filling this out
um they're salaried
this is par this would be part of their
job and
they're only putting in if they have
policies so if they have a policy it's
probably in a file it's probably pretty
easy to take that file and send it off
so it's only if they don't have policies
then you get into all the time and the
money and all that other stuff but we're
not asking them to create policies
we're just saying if the policy is there
send it off and so if the policy is
there it really should be just a few
minutes to click and paste and send off
right because the policies are there and
so that shouldn't be that hard you're
not
you're not
because they're there right and schools
publish those and have those available
that's part of the point
it's just if they're not there
and then
all of that time that money all those
issues we're talking about that's up to
the school to decide whether they want
to do that they could say we don't have
a policy and we don't want to have a
policy end of story they could say we
don't have a policy we didn't even think
about it maybe we should have a policy
then they can spend all the time money
effort etc that they want to develop a
policy
but
that's the local aspect we're just we're
just trying to get them to think about
that you know do they have a policy and
just sending a bulletin
which was a suggestion a lot of times
bulletins oh yeah but if you actually
have to take an action
and say we don't have a policy we do
have a policy
that action in and of itself stirs
further action and so that's the you
actually have to interact with that
question as opposed to just reading and
setting aside so at any rate those are
my comments
thank you this is my final comment um
i've never i was i'm extremely surprised
mike the six lines have taken almost an
hour
as you would be
and when i first started this i thought
you know this has no value this is a
local educational option
the nsp if they have an option they give
you legislation template you bring it to
your lawyer and the thing um so i still
think it's a local education option i
think it doesn't have any value as it is
i do think however she struck a very
important chord in those three areas i
see them as three distinct areas because
they have the conjunctions and um so
those three distinct areas that you
mentioned that it should be in statute
to that i would agree
that if if we think it's that important
that these three policies should which
this does not require but these three
policies should be if you want the local
school boards to have them
then they should be and they have the
process between the superintendents
association or the school board and then
as uh
miss wilson said the school board
typically says here's what you suggest
take it to your lawyer
i do agree that you that this has value
you brought up something not as is
framed but i think your intent now after
listening after an hour has been
illuminated and i would support not this
bill as presented but the concept and
the future of the statute outlining
those three for school boards thank you
mr chair
further discussion
um
it's uh you know i haven't had a chance
really
you must have discussed this amendment
to some degree i didn't have a chance
really or you didn't
ok
that's after lunch
okay mr chair the amendment hasn't been
proposed yet
there's been no militia made
so right now our motion is ought to pass
on on this particular bill um my
and i'll just reiterate where i'm coming
from that there are certain things which
i'd like to see us further study and
look at in terms of
videoing within schools but it my
concerns are not really what's going on
in the classroom my my my concerns are
what's going on in the playground what's
going on in the hallways and entry areas
and all that
and and tying that in with the emergency
management response planning
if
if that's an important aspect of
streaming and communicating
outside of our building to authorities
then i'm all in all in for some kind of
a study to look at how we can ensure
that that we're going to make our
buildings a safer place for kids to be
and staff
to
stream just for the sake of of uh having
some kind of a recording
like we do it's our select board
meetings which are all those we do
stream and we destroy the records after
three years
that's not the purpose this this is just
as perfect said to collect the policies
as a billing principle i used to really
get upset over this type of action and
i'll tell you 100 moffitt that i knew
where this stuff went
when it went up to our central office
and went in somebody's desk stacked up
the pile papers got larger and larger
and there was never a result back to us
as far as what was the purpose of it at
d.o.e i know
i've seen it over there they have an
attic full of stuff up there and
they'll be just it'd just be like
a bottomless pit um i
unlike what we got for the best
practices in in gifted and talented i
think there's some good things which are
going to come out of that process where
we we're going to be able to pursue
the the need perhaps
perhaps not for gifted education be you
know
go beyond just competencies maybe go
through some actual curriculum for those
which are gifted i don't know
but there's there's a lot of good stuff
that comes from that so um
you know i'm willing to look at an
interim study if that's where we think
we need to go and and do this thing more
justice in terms of a wider scope
but if we're not going to go on a wider
scope i have a hard time getting on
board with it
perhaps
famous chair uh again i i've said this
several times um what is happening here
is uh what slowed down gifted before and
what
what i'm hearing from you mr chair is
that
you know all these uh
procedural issues and getting down in
the weeds
uh and that is
that's good and that's what would come
out of this bill if it moved forward uh
but what what's happening
somewhat here is uh
not jermaine to the intended bill the
the intended bit the proposed measure is
simply to
uh do the report you were out of the
room when attorney fenton uh addressed
a bunch of questions related to this i
wish you could have been here to hear
what she had to say but
um
and again i'll finish i know because i'm
the sponsor so i
have to speak to some of these things
as i said earlier looking at the
proposed amendment um i i like it a lot
it exp you know it has more people
reporting and i explain why we try to
keep it simple i would support the
amendment but uh we would need i guess
there's a motion on the floor
and to get to the amendment uh we have
to go through the motion
so
uh
thank you
okay is there any further discussion on
this bill
okay that's i'll call the call the uh
motion madam clerk it's ought to pass
so
can i clarify just as a as a board
member not as a clerk um we're voting on
ought to pass and then if octopass does
not pass then an amendment would come
forward i well
a new motion excuse me possibly with an
amendment
and i haven't heard anybody put forth an
emotion a motion here at the table today
so if we
vote down the ought to pass
then then we'll take another motion
and the motion could be
several motions
excuse me
you could yes you could
so would we withdraw this motion i do
not wish as the sponsor i do not wish to
make the motion the sponsor does not
care to make a motion right now
so basically the motion that we have on
the tables ought to pass on this bill
12.95 okay
okay so this is bill 1295 requiring
reports on excuse me requiring reports
concerning policies on classroom
recordings and in classroom observers
the motion is ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
no
representative blakis yes
represent moffitt
yes
represent hobson yes
represent ford
yes
representative sodie
rosem nelson
representative luno
no
representative waltz
oh sorry
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison
represented mullin no
represent woodcock
represent porter
representative hall no
and chairman ladd no
okay
so
eight
sorry you guys got me right
ten to is that right we have 18 people
okay so um ten days and eight years it
the motion fails
okay so is there uh
there no we have to have a motion on the
bill so there needs to be another motion
that comes forward right do you want me
to make a motion
um represent boom to care to make a
motion
okay so we have a motion for interim
study made by representative boehm and
second by representing luna for interim
study
uh any further discussion from
representatives
any further
eloquent
discussion
thank you very much hobbs
represent hobson
thank you
okay madam clerk would you call the uh
rule uh interim study for 12.95
yes representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes representative blakis
yes i'm sam moffitt
yes represent hobson
yes
representative ford
yes representative saudi yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes
roseanne cornell yes from tanner yes
representative ellison
from sam mullen yes from sam woodcock
represent porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes so interim study
carries 18 to zero okay
any objections to consent
foreign study
no thank you
okay yeah that's that's a good one we
can do we can do from yesterday remember
we had the
that was a bill that had the three
categories in the fourth category was
that you know it dealt with the the
amesbury situation
we can park this bill real quickly i
think because we do have some
information back from the department
which uh representative cordelli like to
present to us so
we're going to open up the hearing now
on that bill that was what was the
number again on that 13 13 13 what
1373. okay let's move to that
if
i might it's relative to the best
interest of the student for a change of
school
or assignment
so 1373 um
uh we asked that further information
being uh gathered uh represent cordelia
has gathered that so before we you know
i have a motion put on on the floor here
why don't you impart to us what you
found out
thank you uh yes this was the situation
where a parent in southampton
or a group of parents
are caught in the situation where their
school has a tuition agreement with
amesbury massachusetts and their high
school
students are sent to amesbury
some of them are unhappy
both with the fact that they're
being forced to send their kids out of
state and they don't think the education
is
really the quality that they want
so they asked about
being able to go before the board and
put forward the idea of tuitioning
instead to
the local
new hampshire school
i was able to find some contact
information
and
actually talked on the phone last
evening
with the parent in southampton
and
there have been developments
in that the
board has agreed
to
provide an option
to tuition students to the
local
new hampshire high school
the issue that has
still caused a situation there
is that the parents will have to
pay the difference in tuition to go to
the new hampshire school and as i recall
it's about eight thousand dollars
the parents would have to pay
to go to a new hampshire school
which is
causing some additional concern
we discussed my legislation
and
i don't see any reasonable way for us to
address
the cost in this legislation and where
it is in statute
i know that
the
parents
state senators
senator sherman was interested in
pursuing
the financial
implications and
how that might be addressed and
you know if it should be addressed in
terms of
what the parent has to pay
so i think that
for this bill
i would like to uh put forward a motion
of interim study
um
just to keep alive the idea of you know
looking at the tuition costs when a
parent
is choosing and has been afforded the
ability to go to a new hampshire school
having to pay thousands of dollars like
that i think is something that we should
look at
yes
so you're are you putting forth a motion
right now yes
okay so we we've had
is octopass on the table
okay so we already have one on the table
so we're in discussion mode right now so
it's ought to pass
so
i could withdraw the motion yeah you
could withdraw the motion who was the
second in that hey for me me okay would
you withdraw the motion also so then we
have no motion on the table so yes
representative cordelia you can put a
motion forward
um i will do so a motion of uh interim
study
second okay so we have that uh represent
cordell you want to further discuss that
bill or
i don't think further discussion is
necessary from me
could i ask a question uh thank you mr
chair may i ask a question about the
discussion you had with the constituent
yesterday rep cordelie
okay uh so i'm i'm confused i wanted to
confirm that the
uh southampton resident had the option
between winneconnet
originally and amesbury
from my conversation previously that was
not an option it was not okay and at
follow-up
the um amesbury school district would
not agree
to transfer the student
it was
if i might the issue was that there was
a tuition agreement a five-year tuition
agreement in place with amesbury
to send their high school students there
uh and so it was a matter of um would
the school board uh provide uh a local
new hampshire option uh for tuitioning
students
i i'd just like to interject one thing
then we'll go around this issue of
tuitioning to
let's say you're a k-8 and you're going
to tuition out to high school
some districts have multiple tuition
agreements
uh some of those schools and i don't
know if it's practice now but it has
been a practice in the past
where it's been an attorney's
delight
where
the difference in the tuition costs
you're up to a colonel now
diane
the the difference in tuition
had to be paid by the family
and when the family came from a
situation that did not have the
wherewithal to pay that difference they
couldn't afford the
that that school they had to go over
here to another tuition
i've heard from some attorneys in fact i
heard from our district attorney
that that was discriminatory
that you couldn't if you had a tuition
agreement as a district
with all these different four or five
schools
then it should be available to all
students regardless of their means
and and so um that that's the issue we
know it's a practice that you know and
i'm sure barrett may have some you know
confirmation if it's still going on or
not but i believe it is going on in the
state in multiple locations so we're
touching upon something that's been
blistering for years
when we start talking about this tuition
stuff with an interim study of some kind
it's
represent boom
yeah thank you we didn't have our high
school we would twist wing to wish we
tuitioning
drink some water
two hudson and manchester but in the
agreement with both was
a percentage
no more than 25
to manchester i got water right now and
no less than 75
to um
to hudson but there was always a gap
that no you know that agreed on both
sides so it was never an issue about
that but yeah there is a an issue and
i'm surprised that much i think it was a
new hampshire school to an after school
there wouldn't be eight thousand dollars
different than tuition
i mean that's surprising with me with
ainsbury 8 000 different than sending a
kid to a new hampshire school
i please don't hold me to that number
but that was my recollection of
our telephone conversation this was just
you know one parent
is there further discussion on
representative porter
this is not a snarky question at all
okay
but isn't it it's my understanding that
that family could they have applied for
an efa
and gotten that tuition money to help
them pay going over to a another public
school i i
asked him about that and
he did not think he would qualify under
the income limits
thank you thank you
any further discussion on this
so we have a motion on the table of
ought to pass no excuse me
interim study interim study
okay um
no more discussion on that
all righty madam clerk please call the
roll
this is house bill 1373
relative to the best interest of the
student for a change of school or
assignment uh the motion on the table is
interim study
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative baum yes representative
lagus yes represent moffat yes represent
hobson yes represent ford yes represent
sony yes represent nelson yes
representative luno yes i'm sam cornell
yeah from tanner yes representative
ellison yes rosa mullen yes roseanne
woodcock
represent porter
from hall yes and chairman ladd
i hate to be the only nobody so i'll go
yes yes
because we don't need another study
okay um
i know it's your kind death
uh
so okay we're gonna take a a break right
now for lunch uh and come back
put some more water in us i need it too
can is there any problem with the
consent for the interim study
we will do it thank you
so we'll break and we'll come back at
one o'clock
is uh
mary beth gone for the rest of the day
she'll be back
you
all right we're gonna get a
you know be called american airlines
here never starting on time or never
arriving on time
but we're pretty close so what we need
to do now is continue um
the executing exact sessions here and we
did uh hop over one of the bills here
earlier today i'd like to go back
and cover that bill that is 11 37
relative to the duty of school boards to
provide education
so if we go
switch you know and cover 11 30 sec look
at find 1137 in our
our books here
and
11 37 i'm i'm gonna look to um
represent boom to make a motion please
and i'll second it
okay uh rip some boom do you have any
discussion on that
yeah
just that it's uh very broad and covers
a lot so i think we really need to look
at
what really school boards should be
doing uh for example superintendent and
all that so i i think it really
it just needs some more study
and that's the second on the motion i
will also echo a little bit of what
ralph just said uh it's a it's a very
broad bill
and it covers uh everything from
structure content
accountability advocacy delivery of
instruction
and then gets onto some
some of the duties of
the board
it's uh got a lot in it and it's
probably got a lot it's missing as well
and so for that reason i also support
interim study
uh
on the bill
uh further discussion representative
cordelli
thank you
if
the motion is defeated i will
offer an amendment
the intent is
of this bill is to address
a number of things that have been going
on in school boards
in new hampshire
there have been
problems um
i'll start with i was go down a list of
a few of the things that i wanted to
address i believe that there are many
school boards who think that they report
to the superintendent as
opposed to the other way around
i think that there have been problems
with parental engagement
people not being listened to people
being shut out
i think this needs to be
remedied and
school boards
should be developing policies to promote
parental engagement
school board members
being silenced being muzzled
just as we represent people and
have a free reign for discussion i think
school board members should as well
the public should be encouraged to
attend board meetings
very often public comment is held at the
end of school board meetings
it could be a late hour uh it
discourages parental intendents
agenda items that they might want to
address have already been
decided with no input from them at the
meeting
it discourages
parental engagement um and i think that
that needs to be remedy and i tried to
do that in this bill
also transparency um is another major
area i tried to address in here
in that um information um
should be eva made available on
curriculum and instructional materials
all should be made made available and be
available to parents
in my local district
um
a group of parents were contacted by the
town prosecutor and told um if you don't
stop with 91a requests for curriculum
materials we're going to refer you to
the state attorney general's office
it goes on
from there
there should be information on each
um
district's website about
a number of areas we had a bill um to uh
provide
uh was it um
cost per student on
ballot measures
i think that all district websites
should have a link to the department
web
site the i platform
series there was a demonstration last
night it's
been greatly enhanced and there's
phenomenal information available there
that should be available to parents on
each district website
with a link to that district information
we have to do more
parents
definitely have a role in their
children's education and those who
believe
otherwise i think are
hurting
public education in this state and in
this nation and i was trying to address
some of those things
in this
legislation
is there further discussion on the bill
yes represent litchfield
thank you
i would just like to echo what
representative cordelli has said um i
could not agree more i just feel that
what's out there right now for school
board members is extremely vague
i've been on the board a couple of
boards for many many years and
it's still very difficult for me to
truly navigate
what my role is i know we hear budget
and policy all the time but you know if
i had a dollar for every time i heard
the superintendent say
that's my decision with regard to any
other staff and administrator you know
you employ me and nobody else it's a
very frustrating and confusing place to
be
and i just want to point out the other
side too
i think
i think it's difficult for board members
and parents from the standpoint of
parents can get very frustrated with
different situations and oftentimes they
will go directly to the board members
they won't necessarily start with the
teacher
go to the principal and the
superintendent they just look at it like
you're bored why aren't you handling
this and it's not even part of the
board's purview so i just think for all
involved at some point we really should
nail this down thank you
thank you um
just for reference here i'd like to
quote a couple areas within statutory
law
in fact if you have your yellow books
you look on page one of that book
and look at rsa 21 n colon one
roman one the general court finds that
the students
parents general citizenry local school
teachers administrators local
governments local school boards
school administrative units state
government have a joint and shared
responsibility for the quality of
education delivered through the public
education system in the state of new
hampshire
so there are a lot of
levels of
or a lot of groups that are involved in
this responsibility and in this system
we call education in the state
then if we turn to some of the duties
that are the responsibility of the
school board on page 308
186 colon 11 to the extent practical
a school district shall make curriculum
course materials available to parents or
legal guardians for review upon request
that's already in law
so are we talking about
us
as a legislative branch of government
getting involved more so in the
governance of local school districts
which are controlled by local elected
officials
because we may see something that is not
what we think is appropriate or not
working
or is it the job of the
the electorate out there
the legislative body of the town to make
that choice and that decision that's the
questions i put out
for us maybe in while we're discussing
this
where's it starting where's it stop
so that yes represent boom
yeah just to follow up on that and what
representative litfield
said i remember when i was on the school
board our policy to the superintendent
is yes you can hire but we have to agree
with it and we took votes on
who the hire
so it's up to the school school board
tells the superintendent what their job
is
not the superintendent telling the
school i think that's really needs to do
need to really look at and make sure
that's being done
so uh
and yeah another thing too following up
on what rick said but
it's
a lot of stuff in law already and that's
what i think we need to really look at
what's already in law and what really
needs to be done
represent lakers
and i think that's the point of this
it's not to change the law
as much it as it is to itemize because a
lot of school board members don't know
what they're supposed to be doing and
don't realize that yes they're the ones
in charge of the superintendent i have
heard that
from school board members in communities
and so this lays it out and says and so
and a bunch of it
is in law that's the whole point it's
laying it out in an organized form that
says these are your duties
and i believe there was a question to
have barrett christina up
well let's get a couple more things out
here first i see a couple hands up first
representative cornell
i i think that in manchester when you're
elected to the school board they go to a
school board orientation
and and it's
they they learn what
the role is of all the school board
members and actually i think the
subcommittees too and they make the
decisions there of what to do and i also
think we have a school charter in
manchester so any changes to anything
that happens on our school board would
have to first everybody would have to
vote that they wanted to have a charter
amendment
a charter committee and then they'd have
to put forth the changes and then
everybody votes on the charter so
i
i don't know that this legislation would
change anything uh or even overrule that
but i'm not sure but i know they all go
to an uh an orientation where they learn
all of the um the rules
or they try to learn they try to learn
they're told
they're i think everybody in this room
went through a legislative orientation
can you remember your half day
orientation or your full day orientation
and did it properly prepare you for the
job you're doing at the table today
you learn as you go right well this year
was a surprise
exactly there's a lot of coffee and
water bottles on the table at this time
i don't see any so maybe if we have
somebody from the school boards
association whether it be uh barrett or
becky
if there are any questions technical
questions that might be asked from us to
you i'm not asking for a testimony that
you might be able to help us in
responding
no okay could you take any technical
questions
thank you are there technical questions
that might come from the uh committee
for the school boards association yes
representative cornell
thank you barry i know manchester does
go to an orientation do is that typical
of all school boards that they are our
new school board members learned things
like that thank you very much for the
question uh representative yes
manchester has mandatory training within
their own
local rules
as i believe it was representative
woodcock asked the question
when the bill was being heard about our
trainings and our orientations
we do
two statewide orientation trainings
every year
we're doing them via zoom now
usually the beginning of may
between the two sessions we get about
maybe 100 120 new school board members
that tune into that
and then in addition to the two webinars
we do orientation we call them our sort
of orientation slash roles and
responsibilities training
um where we you know identify the duties
and responsibilities of school boards
compare and contrast those to the duties
and responsibilities of superintendents
and then hopefully if we're doing our
job right we're able to help school
board members find that sort of middle
ground which is sort of best practices
if you will in addition to the two
webinars um that we do for the
orientations we often go out and do
individual trainings on
roles and responsibilities
to individual
to look to local communities where we'll
do it in person
that request is often made by either the
board chair or the superintendent some
boards have us out every year
um
following march elections even if they
have one new school board member or four
new school board members part and parcel
they ask us to come out every year and
other school boards do it on sort of a
rotating basis and we do anywhere
between
in any given year i think i said 50 to
80 during my initial testimony some
years it's 40 some years it's 60 that we
do of those
thank you very much either for the
question representative mullen
thank you mr chair thank you mr
christina for taking my question does
the school boards association provide
professional development to school board
members and what i'm thinking about
specifically is
as a classroom teacher i had to
literally take
coursework
in something known as how to deal with
difficult people
does is there's literally is there
something like that for school board
members uh
and and
and or is there a manual trying not to
make a joke ladies and gentlemen i'll go
ahead respectfully respectfully you know
my humor by now thank you for the
question representative there is no
mandatory training in new hampshire law
for school board members some states do
have mandatory training for school board
members you have to take x number of
hours within your first year or two
years of being on the board that has
come up
before in this body not in the last i
want to say
10 or 12 years or so
um so you know
it's funny that you ask that about how
to getting along with difficult people
because there are times nhsb is
called out to do a training
and there may be conflict between
a board member and the superintendent or
the board and the superintendent or
sometimes it's between two board members
um
and you know some
there there are times you know my staff
attorney and i will leave a training and
it goes well and there are times that we
leave and say
you know they need therapy they don't
need an attorney so
you know
so i i don't know if that answers your
question but a follow-up thing yes um
in your experience are there school
boards that work well
most school boards i think
work well i mean as as i mentioned in
some of my other testimony i believe it
was on this bill
you know everybody's that have
challenges um either getting along or
moving through their work absolutely but
you know there are 176 school boards in
the state
you know on average if they meet twice a
month how many meetings is that
you know the ones you hear about are are
the outliers you know the ones that are
on channel 9 or
at front page of the union leader
those are outliers you never hear about
the dozens and dozens and dozens of
school board meetings that are running
efficiently where the board's getting
their work done that doesn't make the
news
so
thank you
thank you are there any further
questions of the uh school board
association for advice on technical
things yes represent hobson thank you
thank you mr chair and um thank you
barrett for being here today and for
taking my
comments and questions um first of all i
want to say i have attended some of the
workshops uh with this that the school
board association used to offer where
you would go to the hotel and you go
into the different workshops and i found
that to be extremely helpful
um i i don't know if that's happening
now because of covid it's probably not
the same
um but i was just wondering
uh many times at these hearings we hear
from the school board association and
and um they're they're sort of on the
side of the school
if parents have issues with this with
the school board
in their local community how do you
suggest they bridge the gaps thank you
that's a great question representative
thank you very much um and to your first
part that i believe you're talking about
the kid or law conference
that we have at the graponi um yep um
yeah we did have to do that virtually um
uh in 2021 i guess it was but no we're
back doing those those in person so um
so
to the second question um how can
parents or the community bridge the gap
if they're having challenges with their
own local school board
that's a great question i mean i i think
you know um
raising your concerns initially i think
with usually the board chair is going to
be your first point of contact
a letter or an email
or a phone call my experience is that
many if not most school boards have
their contact information online some
are just an email address and you gotta
hope that email gets responded to
sometimes the phone number is on there
depending on depending on the district
i'd say call your board chair initially
and say i have a concern about this if
it's
you know the potholes in the in the in
the driveway if it's about a you know
perhaps a particular program or course
of study or curriculum
um or you know you don't have a public
comment period or you're doing it at the
end we would ask that you move it to the
beginning or perhaps start with a
conversation with your board chair um
you know raise your concerns
at a public comment portion um during
the meeting um presuming your board
offers that um you know
if need be follow up with a subsequent
um email or letter to the full board
copying the superintendent um
you know
we
you have to you know parents have to
engage with school boards and reciprocal
in in reciprocation of that school
boards have an obligation to be
responsive to the parents and their
constituents um you know talking helps
you know yelling and screaming like what
we saw at some of the meetings last
summer is not helpful um you know but
dialogue can't hurt so i think that
would be the first step and you know if
your board is responsive great if
they're not responsive i would hope that
the board would at least give reasons
why what you're asking for is contrary
to either this particular law
or it's contrary to
you know whatever it might be the ba
says it's not possible in this year's
budget
um
you know i
engage with people
try and be respectful obviously and
again that goes both ways as well too i
mean i think that's the the
the simplest way is is to do it you know
yelling and screaming at a school board
meeting and getting belligerent at a
school board meeting for your three
minutes often doesn't help anything but
if you can have a phone call and have a
cup of coffee as i mentioned before
against some of these hearings these are
your neighbors you know you know
representative i i presume when you got
on your school board it was because you
knew the parents and you knew the
teachers and you knew the kids and they
knew you in the community so they
trusted you and they wanted you to be
their voice that's why they elected you
and you know so you talked to parents
when you were on the school board and
you engaged with parents when you were
on the school board um
you know i'm not crazy about using
social media to engage with constituents
just because that can turn south real
real quick um so but you know i
hope that helps
thank you
thank you represent litchfield
can you help me just so i can direct
other board members or even even myself
where exactly are things if they are
spelled out
and defined exactly what the roles are
of i feel like so i feel like it's very
vague and if i could just if you humor
me for a minute um with an example
so i've annually pretty much sat through
your training i very much appreciate it
i'm gonna have to say that when i've
gone to your offices and you've taught
let's say on default budgets etc changes
in the laws
extremely helpful i've gone back and
taught constituents budget committee
members everything so i want to first
say thank you for that
but
when it comes to initially being elected
um you know you're you're brought in
regardless of who the superintendent is
event there were a few where you they
have that talk you that you handle
things behind close right
it i'm just keeping it real i know what
people don't like to hear but no
surprises you handle things behind
closed doors um only the board chair
responds to things which is difficult
especially in a co-op right because it
makes it look like you're unresponsive
if you don't and these are all things
that i'm sure
that you've heard about before
so
for me personally
i just want to know
where can i look if i had a dollar for
every time i have heard you i you just
work you know i just you just do my
review or i just work for you whatever
but you have no say about any
administrators or what they're doing or
knowing what's going on um if i had a
dollar for every time i heard that i
could take you guys to a street lunch
right now so i just want to understand
where where can i get that information
so i stop asking you every time you sit
in that seat
thank you thank you for the question
representative um
most of the statutes and the rsas and
189 are going to be pretty
broad and and vague if i don't want to
say vague but pretty broad
you're not going to find
a a list of
school boards do this
a b c d so on and so forth and you're
not going to find a list that says
superintendents do this a b c d the more
directive i guess the i think the first
place to look would be the department of
education rules in the 300 series
302 is the duties and responsibilities
of the superintendent there's 302.01 and
302.02
ed
303.01 is roles and responsibility or
duties and responsibilities of school
boards okay
also look at the department of education
rule 306 the minimum standards
the beginning aspect of that and you
know this represents because you've been
to our trainings you're always the
a-plus student at each of those
um
you know we talk about all the policies
that are required by law and you know we
talk about policy work being you know
the the first aspect of good school
board governance that's because the
minimum standards ed 306.04
talk about the school board shall adopt
the following policies and there's a
list of
25 policies that are required by law and
if you were to go to 306 and do a word
search of board you're gonna get a 500
hits so just be mindful of that
it will say the board shall develop a
plan the board shall develop
a policy if you will
so
you know on
so you're not going to find a
comprehensive list of boards do this
administrators do this
we also have to be mindful that we have
rsa 194
dash c colon 4.
duties and responsibilities of
superintendents we've got the doe rules
that i've talked about we also have um a
provisioning statute and again that's
probably got 20 paragraphs a through
qrr that talks about the superintendent
is responsible for
payroll cash flow payroll you know
payroll um
management of federal grants you know
duty and supervision of employees and
students um
a whole whole list of things that are
within the duty of the responsible
responsibility of the superintendent
one of the reasons that hsba advocates
so strongly that policy work is the
basis of good governance is because by
policy work you are directing your
superintendent
how you want him or her to do the job in
what manner you want them to do the job
because no law is going to be complete
no department of education here's the
way i look at it we have statutes right
we have the rsas
the minimum standards and the department
of education rules fill in a lot of gaps
for the statutes they help clarify right
but then your local policies then help
implementation of those department of
education rules at the local level and
to some degree that's where one of the
last vestiges of local control is
through those school board policies
where the department of education may
have a rule that says school boards you
have to adopt a policy on homework this
is just one example it doesn't say what
that policy has to include so local
boards are then free to determine is
their homework policy going to count
towards grades how much is going to be
given every night are there guidelines
10 minutes per classroom or per per
grade level is sort of i think a
standard that educators use from time to
time
so
you know
there isn't going to be a comprehensive
list representative about again as i
said about
whose territory this is and whose
territory this is um to some degree some
of these department of education rules
and the 194 c4
there's some level of contradiction from
time to time you know within the
statutes and within the rules so policy
can help clarify that but you know
nothing
you know nothing is
nothing can help better than i think
positive
board superintendent relationships
ascertaining how things are going to get
done what things are going to get done
you know how the board wants to see them
to see them done i mean you know if you
look at some of those department of
education rules and and the statutes um
relative to the superintendent's duties
you know it talks about the
superintendent is responsible for
evaluating staff so to some degree
that's not a board's issue
if you know if if there's a problem in
the second grade classroom and you're
getting those calls from your
constituents
the board has
one as an individual board member you
have no legal authority to do anything
you understand that but two the board
doesn't have any legal authority to do
to do any to do that either the
recommendation to hire or to non-renew
has to come from the superintendent
i mean that's not
that's not me that's not nhsba saying
that that's what the statute says and it
seems to have worked that way for a
number of years superintendent nominates
right and the board elects you know that
language um
so you know so so that's if if if the
parent is upset with something is it is
it pertinent for them to to to to
contact the board and let the board know
of the complaints well yeah for i mean
so the board has an idea of what's going
on but that doesn't mean the board has
any legal authority to resolve the issue
you know you've got to talk to the
parent to the teacher you've got to talk
to the principal you've got to talk to
the superintendent and are you going to
go into a non-public session with one
parent to talk about their particular
issue maybe maybe not but if you want to
do that to let them have their say you
can but if you're doing that to
potentially resolve an issue again you
don't have you meaning the board doesn't
have any authority to do that it's just
that's the way the law is set up and you
know unfortunately sometimes the answer
is no sometimes the answer's got to be
no
so
i i was a i was a long way to get to
your question representative i hope i
answered and i hope i provided some info
you gave me an aha moment so i want to
say thank you for that we're giving away
our power through policy
at times
not always that would that would be your
board's decision yeah thank you you're
welcome
just just a point of clarification which
i think supports where you are a select
board's in the same domain the town
manager
hires
and fires it's not the select board
and unless you have a town administrator
which have different capacities and
different roles from each other
so it's not too different than what we
see on the municipal side as well sure
uh can i i'm sorry representative can i
follow up just to represent litchfield's
last comment um
you said that boards are exceeding their
power and authority via policy that that
may be one way of looking at it
i'm aware of one school school board
that
felt that the board should be in charge
of everything and that the
superintendent should be subservient
went through sample policies or not not
sample policies their policies their
their school boards policies everywhere
in policy where it says the
superintendent shall
they struck that out and wrote the board
so
the board was involved and you know to
some point where it became unmanageable
all i won't say how many school board
members there were because that may give
away what board but that board would
have been working
24 7 quote unquote managing the school
district which is not the board's
responsibility
so and there's there's a there's got to
be a balance in there i recognize that
and that balance is going to be
community to community
did you have a question yeah
i've always had this concern even when i
was on the school board later about the
school board also having
your judicial responsibility which means
the school board can't know that's right
what is going on in a lot of cases
because they might have to act as a
judge
for a situation which i always found to
be a problem because you know what's
going on especially in small school
districts right yet you can't do
anything about it because you've got to
i mean my concern was
maybe something better than something
like the selectmen do is
have somebody you appointing former
members yeah to act as a judiciary i've
i mean
thanks for the question representative i
just just so
the non-school board members that are on
this committee from time to time a
school board has to serve as an
adjudicative body where you have a
student hearing or a staff hearing where
you're impacting somebody's rights
you're either suspending a kid
um from school or or firing a a teacher
or terminating a teacher or non-renewing
a teacher so the board is serving as
judge and jury if you will and there's a
hearing
the teacher the student is there almost
the defendant if you will and they've
got their attorney
and the the superintendent and the
principal are sitting there as the
prosecutor with their attorney and then
the board is sitting up as us as a judge
with their attorney
um
if you got three attorneys in the room
you probably should have done some
things to not get to that point in the
first place
um
and and exactly which is you know
another reason that we have to caution
our our members about you how to be
mindful when you're when you're taking
these complaints and these concerns from
these parents because
they may be biasing you or prejudicing
you and if it's something that may get
to a hearing
you've got to serve as judge and judy
judge and jury excuse me um
you've gotta you know you've gotta be
mindful that you don't bias yourself and
i've never run into it myself but i know
some of my um uh colleagues that
represent school districts have run into
that time and time where the board
members have posted something on
facebook where they were clearly buy
some prejudice and they had to run
around town trying to find i think they
found a couple former board members i
think they found an attorney in town but
it was a it was a pain in the butt you
know it was difficult so yeah i mean you
know do we create some sort of tribunal
you know that's not associated with the
the district to hear this sort of thing
i i don't know it's
but it's it's and it's small the smaller
the district the harder it is because
you know the kids and you know the
families and you know the teachers and
that's why you ran for school board
because you know the kids because you
know the parents and you know the
teachers right
right right representative that's why
you run for school board i know i know
how this works
represent lakers you have your hand up
yeah thank you
um
given
the um
i'm not sure what the right word
acrimony maybe that we've seen
in
some school districts
and
do you think
that having something like this
would help
preemptively diffuse that
thank you for the question
representative i mean i haven't i didn't
i haven't contemplated in that angle i
believe when rep when the bill was first
being heard i think representative baum
asked something similar wouldn't this
help us develop the policies and the
trainings and um again i think it was
representative litchfield asked you know
do you know we opposed a bill was there
anything in here that we did support and
i think i went through and i highlighted
a couple that we didn't necessarily have
specific objections to
um
so
you know i i i think my previous
testimony you know indicated um
you know school boards are already doing
a lot of these things and we have
policies you know on all these things
could there be better methods of perhaps
broadcasting that to parents and the
public that we have a policy on
community engagement
fine that that's that that may be a
legitimate legitimate concern within
within a particular community so um
again specifically that angle i hadn't i
hadn't considered representative but
you know it's a good question
and then a follow-up yes
and um
you're working with just your member
districts right
um
by and large yes i mean we have most
school boards in the state and we don't
work you know we we work with we have
161 members that are members of the
nhsba new hampshire school boards
association we work with them and we
also work very closely with the
superintendents as well too
okay because i was thinking about how
this might help
the other school boards yeah well
you know
the ones that are not members of nhsba
are typically either districts that do
not have schools there are some small
schools up on the mountain there's
districts in the mountains that they
don't have they don't have a facility
they got 20 kids so they put them on a
bus and ship them over the mountain
right um and then some of the other
really small like a k through two k
through three where the school board
meets once a month and it's you know
again maybe 15 20 kids in the district
so
they don't
they don't i guess they don't feel the
need to utilize our services which is
understandable
okay thank you yep thank you are there
any other uh technical type
questions we may have
i don't see any hands and i really
appreciate your coming forward my
pleasure thank you very much mr chair
and thank you all
so we have a motion on the floor and the
motion is to interim study
uh this bill
uh is there any further discussion on
that
madam clerk would you please call the
rule
yes
uh bill number 1137 relative to the duty
of school boards to provide education
and the emotion is interim study
representative cordelli no
representative litchfield is no
representative beaum
oops representative lakes no
represent moffett
yes
president hobson
no
representative ford
yes
represents
no
representative nelson
representative cornell yes
representative tanner
yes
president ellison yes
and chairman ladd yes
so the interim study motion carries 12
to 6.
okay there i'm sure is there a
minority report
from
before we leave
okay before we leave okay
thank you very much we will move on now
to the next bill on the docket for today
i can find my location here
jumping down to
i think 1381 was the next bill which we
had relative to student school board
members 1381
this bill allows for at least one
student member on the school board from
each public high school in the district
or those people are wondering what the
bill is all about
um i'm looking to um for a motion from
representative cordelli
uh thank you i'd like to move uh itl
is there a second i'll second
representative cordelli's motion
represent cordelli do you have
any discussion
uh just that i i don't think this is
necessary um
local boards can uh have student
representatives or not
um
i i just don't see the need for this
legislation
and representative moffat
uh what representative cordelia said
thank you
further discussion yes representative
woodcock
thank you chairman
um i would disagree with the other two
gentlemen i just previously spoke having
served on a school board for 20 years
um i found it very effective to have the
student voice right there particularly
with questions about what's going on in
the schools i understand it's not a
voting delegate but than this data
provider put in and that that
recognition that students are
the clients here they are the people who
are servicing and have their input in a
school board meeting particularly people
who may not have been in school for 20
or 30 years i think it's very very
critical so i think it's making a
mistake not allowing this this access to
have young young men and women at a high
school level these are young adults
these are what a great opportunity for
leadership for the future
thank you thank you any further
discussion represent cordelia
yes i just add that this is making it
mandatory to have a student
member but also specifying
the number
of student representatives because it
requires one from each high school at
least
further discussion representative luno
thanks very much
and
i think i think maybe a couple of years
ago i may have introduced a bill
similar to this or along the same lines
as this
i served on a school board for 12 years
every one of those years we had
at least one
usually two
high school uh students as um as as
student members of the board non-voting
you know
certainly follows along the lines
of this and uh and and really i agree
with what um with what representative
woodcock was saying in terms of a
leadership opportunity but also what
what an education in civics uh to be on
a governance board and uh and play a
role in
in governance working with
the administration and then working with
the the legislative body at uh at school
district meetings and it's just a
wonderful opportunity and i think every
high school should uh should provide
that opportunity to uh to their students
thank you
further discussion representatives
i think students see some parts of
schools
and experience some parts of schools
that maybe others aren't seeing or
aren't as aware of and having that
student perspective
just as a bringing up issues and i have
heard
um
stories from some people who were
this position
uh in their town because and they
uh
brought up things to the school board
the school board had no idea and which
needed to be addressed
and boy would i have liked to have been
able to
do something like this when i was in
my high school
because we certainly there were a number
of us students who saw things
and we were just students and nobody
paid any attention to it but i think it
would have saved a lot of grief on some
on a bunch of students had we been able
to have a voice at least to be heard
about some of the things that we saw
thank you
representative boom
thank you miss chad just to bring up uh
back in the first year i was on the
house education committee
i brought the first bill i brought up on
this committee was to allow more than
one member of the school board because
we were having two members
and found out that it was illegal but
you can't have two but anyway we so
that was my first bill and i think it's
a great idea and if some school board
does not have it they're missing a lot
but one per school high school i think
that might be a lot best like in
manchester or five
but and they
rotate
uh yeah it's nice to find out what's
actually going on in the school
but i think the current law is really
sufficient
um
and for example when i brought up when i
did my
yrbs
thing uh
the principal when the principal came in
with
the disastrous results and i mentioned
to them no nil the kids all took this as
a joke and the school board the student
representative agreed with me so yes you
you need that
and it'd be nice but you can't do it to
have a a private and private thing with
your school board to find out what's
really going on in the school but you
can't do that but yeah i think it's
definitely needed but
it i think the current law
is sufficient thank you
representative porter
thank you mr chair one of the joys of my
time serving in the legislature were the
years that i was the educ legislative
co-chair of the new hampshire
legislative youth advisory council
they're a group of young people who are
appointed to
advise the legislature on issues that
are important to young people in the
state and i'm very proud of the work
that they have done in the past and i'm
very proud of them this term too
although i'm no longer heading them up
but i do have here a list of
bills that they have been
meeting and discussing and deciding what
position they would like to take and one
of them is this bill
i want you to know that they have a
subcommittee or an interest group
that works on education issues and that
group has
recommended that this bill ought to pass
so i want you to know that from them
that that's where they stand on on this
issue and um
they're really special kids they're good
it's good a good organization thank you
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman i do think they
should be i have a question how does
confidential confidentiality fit into
this if
uh something comes up to the school
board do they get to vote
they don't they don't vote
yeah one of the one of the questions i
have
represented muffin in a second please
i have is the legislation states that we
have on the books right now
may choose by a simple majority to to
add one or more
so currently
you can have one represented from each
high school if that's uh individual
board so deems it necessary so i'm
trying to find determine my own mind
here how has this really changed what
we're capable of doing right now
representative moffitt
thank you mr chair
excuse me um
i agree with uh the sentiments that
several of you said about the
nice thing about having involvement
civic involvement by students i i get
that and i
understand that
my little concern of this a couple of
them uh you know would they
as
members of the school board they be
expected or allowed to attend or not
attend non-public sessions
would probably be a local uh
call on that probably not
but but beyond that uh a hallmark of how
we do business in new hampshire is
school board local control so here's
here's a bill uh philosophically that we
have the state coming in and saying you
shall have a student i think it's great
that they do they should just the notion
of the state saying you shall have at
least one student that's just something
that uh
was you know bought me just a little bit
which is why i seconded the uh
the motion
further discussion represented woodcock
thank you just very brief thank you
chairman
194 223 tell you exactly what the school
in school school young says kenny can't
do uh in section five deals with
nelson's question
what it is now is enabling it's enabling
legislation
they have laid out whoever wrote this it
could have been
representative obama's group way back
then
but in either case it tells you exactly
what they do and they're good at it this
just says it gives the opportunity
because some schools don't want them
don't have them don't know they should
this is just it's just a powerful piece
to have in your schools to have a
youngster there who's in the high school
as we said who knows what's going on
and anne is the conduit from the high
school students to the board
it provides another opportunity for
their input
thank you
represent
yeah it's been my experience in uh
windham uh that if kids have grievances
they come in and testify themselves
so that's all i gotta say
representative litchfield
thank you
if i could throw this out to all of you
that that have spoken up on this or have
a thought
here's my concern my concern is just
as an elected official and as a board
member
whenever i've spoken up about something
that's not very popular
i get the email the next day that says
come into my office
or call me
as an adult board member so my concern
is we're talking about let's say
students and i respect what you're
saying i don't disagree but students
will bring things to light i worry for
those students especially in any
district or the larger district but if
they're bringing things
to light that may not be comfortable for
all involved
how is that for the students that night
or the next day when it comes to the
board when it comes to the staff members
when it comes to
the other students and parents in the
district um
i just i worry for them i guess is my
point um and
they can already do this anyway but i
just want you to know that's this is
where my thought process is coming from
if we mandate it
further questions representative
and then represent cornell yeah i just
wanted to respond to that in that if
students have these concerns and try to
bring them to a board and are just
ignored because they're just students
and have to see and feel the
consequences of that that is also
disturbing and troubling
represent cornell
well in manchester you know we do have
the four high schools and there are
student representatives now from it and
i don't see it as airing grievances or
bringing bad things forward to the
committee as i think i said when this
bill first came up
one student who's a representative
rewrote the school dress code which i
think hadn't been done since the 80s so
it was time to redo and now reflects you
know what students within reason and
they were very responsible about writing
this i mean nothing inappropriate isn't
it so i see it as a positive thing and
when i've watched and seen what they've
reported they talk about what's going on
in their schools things they
legitimately have concerns about they
report good things and they and they add
to the discussion and they're there to
answer questions if the school board is
discussing something and they want to
find out something so i think this is a
great idea
is there any further discussion
representative tanner
i was just wondering if we could ask
mr christina
if he had any idea how many school
boards in the state of new hampshire
actually have student representation on
it
thank you for the question
representative i don't know we don't
it's not something we track
representative mullen
thank you mr chair uh in response to
representative tanner's question
uh it was
with
great surprise that i discovered as a
result of the legislative hearing on
this bill
that
my school district does not have any
student representation on the school
board
so in looking and digging into the
statutes i think some of the confusion
comes between 189 1c
and 194 23 f
because there are maze in 189
1c
and shells in
194 23 f
but the bottom line is that um
yeah some i think the student voice is
inherently important in every school
district
regardless of whether or not we're happy
with the message they're delivering we
need to listen to what they have to say
and uh to make room for them at the
table
thank you thank you is there any further
discussion on the bill
see any madam clerk would you call the
roll please
yes this is house bill 1381 relative to
student school board members the motion
on the table is
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lacus no
represent moffett
yes
represent hobson yes
representative ford
no
representative sodi yes
representative nelson
no
represent blue now no
representative waltz no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
or sam ellison
represent mullen no represent
woodcock represent porter
reserve hall no
and chairman ladd yes
so the itl carries 12
just kidding it doesn't i'm sorry i'm
sorry just kidding there were seven
years and 12 knees
so the motion fails
so another motion
representative
i'd like a motion to otp please
we have a motion on the table to otp the
bill from uh represent lakers and second
from represent woodcock represent lakers
i think you've pretty much heard my
arguments
represent woodcock
thank you for the opportunity for the
students
further discussion
now clerk please call the roll
representative hall i just asked the
question so what if
the school board um
it says they must have one if they put
it out there and ask for one so what
would happen if a student didn't come
forward
representing moan i think i have the
answer to that in 194 it says
that the school must select one or more
so i think the responsibility goes back
to the high school or uh whatever school
it is that is selecting the student
great thanks
but within the school there's also the
student government or the student
council
which you're going to have to have to
replace somebody that leaves at
mid-year or
already graduated something such as that
so
it doesn't
it does imply that
at least state to me that you would have
to have a student government of some
kind in that high school
or student election for the position and
we have in conway the over election so i
mean there's it's not it hasn't been an
issue of students wanting to get there
they all like the opportunity
and i i would think that most of them
have student councils too but you know
um you may not who knows okay uh we got
a motion on the table
clerk is there anything nothing else
so the motion on the table is ought to
pass regarding bill 1381 relative to
student school board members
representative um cordelli
no
representative litchfield is no
representative boehm
representative blakis yes president
moffatt
no
representative hobson
yes
representative ford
representative saudi no
representative nelson yes
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative allison ellison
represent mullin yes
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd
no okay
so the ought to pass um passes
14 to 4.
there will be a minority report mr
chairman
yes mr chairman i think 14 to 4 is 18
people and i thought we had 19 members
[Laughter]
no that will not go on consent and there
will be a minority report
put my name down
okay um
make sure we're going in the order we
should be here
see how we have one two three four
five
bills to go
okay we have five bills to go and
in order to get these done today we're
gonna have to scoot along
uh i'm gonna be out of here so it's
definitely over at 3 30. i've got
another meeting that just came and
starting at 2 30 in finance
so
we'll do what we can do
yeah okay
um
1434 relative to the availability of
schools curriculum materials
yeah go ahead
i
call upon chairman ladd for a motion
yes i like to uh
make a motion of ought to pass
for a second
it's it's okay you don't have to fight
over the second
yeah
and i'd like to uh
make a recommendation a motion to uh
approve uh amendment 0803h
i think this was passed out the other
day there's more of them right here
at one point in time they were
yeah some of them have gone around
they've been on the table for quite a
while
um
is there a discussion mr chairman
yep it's coming
all set to proceed with discussion
great
uh chairman ladd okay uh was there a
second on the uh
yeah okay thank you um
the amendment which i'm uh putting forth
changes the statutory number on the bill
from 189 10 a which was in
the
bill as stated that comes under an area
in legislation called studies which
we're kind of using that for things like
health and physical education etc etc i
think
it rather belongs under school board
duties under 189 colon 1a
which is specifically titled duties to
provide education and what this
amendment does
upon a request of a parent a guardian
or a
a member of the public the school board
shall within 10 business days provide
adopted curriculum and instructional
goals
used by for providing students learning
experiences
regarding the knowledge and skills
taught in grade level course and program
at each school operated and governed in
the district
the added language there to 189 one
there's various terminology in there
that replicates what was already in law
which speaks to instructional goals as
responsibility of the school boards and
it also talks about
the
the govern in its district
which we talked about down below
um
let's see
in online um
seven it also says uh each school
operated and governed in its district
and so the language which is do have
placed in the amending language is
already in 189 but this specifically
says that if a parent requests it
it's available to them it should be
available to them within 10 business
days of the request thank you
further discussion representative
cornell
i i well it's a question um so this
takes out the part of that it's
accessible on the website and that
there's a physical copy available
everything that's in the original bill
is how to accept this blackened area
that you see
in the amendment okay so how
further yes how would it be made
available you can say um it's on the
website go to this link and
that's enough
um it's available upon request so it
does not have to be posted on the
website it could be
in the principal's office it could be
located in the library a parent would
come in and have access to or this dual
district office uh it doesn't say
anything about having to post it or make
copies or anything of that sort
thank you
representative ellison uh thank you mr
chair uh rick just a question on on
language or interpretation language
lines 10 and 11
specifically adopted curriculum and
instructional goals
i
i i'm trying to
in my own mind figure out whether in
adopted curriculum
is is one category and instructional
goals are is a second category are those
two things tied together and i would
only i would only raise the question in
terms of if it's a book
that a
a parent objects to
is that are we talking about part of the
curriculum the book is part of the
curriculum so therefore it comes under
this piece of legislation
or more general adopted curriculum
instructional goals which would not
include that sort of question
the
the definition which we have for the
word curriculum
if you look in statute
and i'm reading it from it's inadequacy
in in the content of adequacy it says
curriculum means the lessons in academic
content taught in school or in a
specific course or program
okay um so we're talking about that
academic content i.e the knowledge and
skills which are taught
uh and but this is specific of the
approved stuff
by the
by the board
um so um
or it's not adopted adopted
thank you so
represent luna thank you very much mr
chair um
so so to the um
looking at this paragraph um
that's being amended here uh it appears
to be
all about instruction
establishing the structure
accountability advocacy and delivery of
instruction and that's what school board
shall be responsible for establishing
the structure accountability averaging
delivery of instruction and then it goes
goes down through that diverse
educational approaches
instructional policies that establish
instructional goals
and so in the bold
you're referencing and this this sort of
goes to what representative allison was
was i think inquiring about you're
referencing two things you're
representing you're you're referencing
adopted curriculum and you're
referencing instructional goals but this
paragraph only talks about instructional
goals being established by the board
um and and i could certainly understand
that those instructional goals having
been established in roman two
should be made available to parents upon
request but the adopted curriculum
in the bold here doesn't tie into
anything that's in roman two however it
does
tie into
186 colon 11
roman 9
c
which at the and this is on page 308
of the yellow annotated
the rsas
um
sort of sort of
a third of the way down the left-hand
column
so 186
186 11. roman
would i say roman 9 c
uh quote to the extent practicable a
school district shall make curriculum so
now we're talking about curriculum make
curriculum course materials available to
parents or legal guardians for review
upon request
the name of the parent or guard or legal
guardian and any specific reason to
disclose to school officials for the
objection of the material shall not be
public information shall be excluded
from access under rsa 91a
so so i guess
i'm i'm i'm
i would i would i would suggest that
maybe the
the adopted curriculum part is already
being provided for
an existing law
the instructional goals i think is a
good catch and and has not been
addressed as as sort of like a that that
that it can be requested and the
um
district shall provide
so
what what i'm trying to do is that
within the adopted rules for this state
if you were to look at ed 306
0.14
which deals with the local school board
shall require that each school has an
instructional program which includes the
following if you go down to item number
four
it says instructional materials and
resources
match to the appropriate skill levels of
students
and um
a lot of this that we have that uh folks
are looking at i'm trying to write this
in such a way
that it's it's uh
providing to the
the person requesting the information
which is available
and the the school board should have
available or the school district or the
school
and and right now according to rule we
should all have instructional materials
and resources that match
the the outcomes were or the student
learning that we're
working towards there's got to be some
material in these schools instructional
goals instructional resources
instructional materials because
you know you write down i don't want to
get in a laundry list of things i don't
want to get into writing down the
textbooks and then we get all those
textbooks down there and we're putting
them on the web and let's say getting
into the uh um
the materials used in your preschool
program or your kindergarten program
where you're getting all or the mortons
in math blocks for teaching mathematics
which are all kind you can't do that
and we shouldn't have to do that but
there should be some
curriculum outlines or instructional
goals
materials resources
available so a parent can come in and
see oh that's what's being taught my
child at this particular grade level or
in this course or in this program which
is a combination of courses
that's the intent of this the intent is
not is to get away from all the laundry
list to get away from the education
alphabet soup and to just make it
complain and easily understood and there
may be some room for interpretation i i
don't mind that i what i think we need
to do is just
be open and have the materials which
we're using available i in no way i'm
expecting to have lesson plans
read and reviewed by the parent um
that's the only one that should be
overseeing that is the building
principle or the supervising teacher
so that's where it stops so what i'm
trying to do is get something in here
which kind of responds to what some of
the parents are requested
but it's something that i think's being
done
i think that's the stuff is available
the the first step is
you have to come ask talk to teacher i'm
sure you'll get it immediately
or then you talk to the principal to
whomever and you'll be directed in the
right direction so that's what i'm
trying to emphasize and and mr chair i'm
on board with what you with what you
just said
and and
and
and specifically where you just said
that the the curriculum can be is
available and may be requested
uh by a parent and shall be provided by
the school district because it's right
there in 18611
what what isn't and i'm i'm saying it's
a good catch here is that as school
boards also establish instructional
goals
that that that school boards establish
the instructional goals and those
instructional goals um may be requested
and shall be provided
and and
you know i would i would say this this
amendment so as not to duplicate what's
already in 8611
um and so that it focus on on the the
the purpose of roman 2 in the amendment
which is instruction
um
and the school boards establishing
instructional goals that that the bold
focus on on
making the the instructional goals
available within the 10-day
window
what about instructional materials and
resources that's spoken in in ed 306
you're not going to find it there well
you're not finding it here either so
i'm saying don't don't the parents want
to know that
what's your what you're using as far as
so i can also have right now the
textbooks are not going home in my my
district we don't have textbooks anymore
and wouldn't it be nice for a parent to
have something that they can
themselves update themselves and how to
teach this particular lesson or provide
you know some information for them and i
think you were saying that that's
already available and i think it is
available in 186.11. 186.
yeah roman 9
page 308 okay about a third of the way
down the left-hand column okay
i trust you
yeah so yeah okay that's the one where
you know i read earlier today
right right yeah yeah that's why i had
it at my fingertips
so basically what this is that says when
practical and and uh
they will be made available
um it says to the extent practicable
yeah and i think that's a very important
piece too because that means if it's if
it's available electronically then it
may be provided electronically it's
available in print then it may be
provided in print
yeah i i you know
representative hopson i kind of like the
word review and you able to come in you
can look at the stuff uh i don't know
how you're ever going to get this all in
online
well if it's already possible yes you
can't do it and it's constantly changing
that's why to the extent practicable
isn't important yeah
okay and it's an existing statute
representative hobson
thank you
i don't know which one of you is sharing
this at this point
um thank you for taking my question i
have a couple of questions uh first one
is um
the the three of you senior veterans
are going through the rsas very quickly
and i'm a little confused as to which
rsas you're talking about i've heard
school districts mentioned michelle
provide and i this particular
amendment references school boards
so um that is my first question which
if
all i i think that the most recent
discussion was in relation to 186 roman
9 c
on page 308 yes correct and that's
that's school district
and the amendment here is school board
and and
um attorney fenton might be able to
clarify this but i think school board
and school district are almost used
interchangeably throughout the statutes
do you have a follow-up question
i have a follow-up so as a
as a prior school board member i don't
know that i was ever
i probably had the ability to request
curriculum but it was not available at
my fingertips which uh and i don't know
that it should be i'm not saying that
but if it's a duty um and the other
right but it's a duty because it's
because the school board's the governing
body right so so it doesn't mean that
the school board member would actually
be providing the curriculum but but the
gov
the governing body has the responsible
for making sure that the school that the
district
provides it so it would come through the
the the administration okay yeah it
wouldn't come from so it's this is kind
of a follow-up did you want to ask
when practicable
um to me
i
that um
seems um
to be
an interpretive
question so and i'd maybe you know
this is just me as a school board member
parent type of a representative
perspective right right yeah it doesn't
say when practical practicable it says
to the extent practicable and and that's
an important distinction because because
it means is it available this way is it
available this way
is it available that that you come in
and review it in in
a classroom because they only have one
textbook left or something like that
that's that's what that means
would you uh interpret that um your
comment to the extent practical if they
have it available in hard copy form um a
parent coming in and wishing an
electronic form it would not be to the
extent practical to then convert it to
electronic formatting yeah i i think
that's a fair um interpretation of that
especially if it's a 400 page textbook
or something like that if it's if it's
you know a a 12-page
i i don't know yeah course outline or
something like that sure scan it in it's
probably on a word document somewhere so
i i mean
yeah uh further questions representative
tanner
thank you um you know i think a lot of
this is in course of studies i mean and
i i read this and as a teacher a former
teacher i have no idea
what i would have to provide i mean i
really don't um
they
the courses that i taught
didn't have textbooks and most courses
don't anymore because textbooks are out
of sight expensive number one and within
a couple years they're outdated and so
long ago the schools decided that was a
good way to save money and so
a lot of course material is is online
but i i just turned to kearsarge's
program of study and looked up
personal finance which is one of the
things that we kind of pushed them to do
and it says this semester-long course is
designed to introduce students to basic
personal financial skills
students will learn about investing
managing their money credit buying a
home vehicle risk management and
consumer rights to me that is their
instructional goals students will learn
the use of checking and savings accounts
and become knowledgeable in the process
of planning for retirement
um
to me
uh i've met the
you know that's that's what i would
think that a parent would want to see
now
i don't know
it almost seems like
when you say
for providing students learning
experiences we're digging into
what happens in the classroom which is
instruction and and
i think we've talked about this before
but teaching is an art
it isn't something that
maybe as a student teacher or first or
second year teacher you've got
everything mapped out you might even map
it out by time blocks um
because
you're you're learning as you're going
what what goes over what doesn't
you know how to work with kids you're
learning a lot of things as you're doing
it as you get more experienced you know
you're you're able to flip a
instruction
on a dime because you realize right away
that you need to take a different avenue
and um
you know i just
uh we have competencies that are kind of
uh what the expected knowledge and
skills are at grade level in each area
most i think every school has
competencies we now have these things
called rubrics
which are the ways students get to the
competencies and those are you know
right out there for the students they're
given to the students so the students
know what they have to accomplish
i'm not sure what it is in elementary
school
i'm assuming middle school is pretty
close to high school on a lot of these
things but
again
you know i realize what you're trying to
do
but as a teacher
i'm not sure
what i would have to provide and that's
and that's why i i have difficulty with
this
yeah i think
my recollection from the uh introduction
by the chair is that um instructional
goals is referred to in line eight
and i think that that's
where the chair was coming from in
his drafting here
are there further comments uh
representative lacus
yeah the the thing i like about this
that i objected to on all the other ones
when they're talking about
making
curriculum etc available to
parents is that the other ones all had
you do it beforehand
and as rep tanner was saying as a
teacher you switch on a dime you know
you're planning you're changing and all
of that stuff but this doesn't have to
do it beforehand it has to do it
within 10 business days after they
request so in my mind this is
what i am doing what i have done
and so all those things you said most of
them are online and it would be easy for
me as a teacher to send those off
because i've done them already they're
already there i'm not saying what i will
be doing in the future other than my
goals right my instructional goals but
as far as the other stuff it doesn't
seem to be asking and maybe i'm reading
it wrong
um
but that was what i like because it's
not saying 10 days in advance i have to
tell all the things i'm going to do
which the others did it just seems to be
saying i have to let them know what i'm
doing and so i'm doing it so i can put
in
what i'm doing right the things i've
just done and and if i didn't give a
parent enough i'm sure they're going to
say
you know i was really looking more for
this
and then i can accommodate them but
that's that's why i'm supporting this
one i didn't support any of the other
ones
thank you further
thank you
representative cordelia i just have a
question so i'm looking at the third
grade mathematics curriculum map that's
on our school district website
it starts off with a paragraph about in
grade three students continue to work on
numeration geometry measurement and
problem solving blah blah blah blah blah
student multiplication division graphing
but okay so there's a a paragraph
narrative about what the kids are going
to do during the year
and then underneath that are the course
standards and that though that says by
the end of the school year a student
should be able to
and then it says
operations and algebraic thinking and it
lists what they should do numbers and
operations in base 10
fractions measurement data and there are
instructional points there
would that cover
what it is that is being asked for in
the bill if there was a narrative about
what the kids would do during the year
and then course standards listed out
i think you just identified the
instructional goals that are for the
third grade
right that's what we would like to have
communicated to the parent you know via
this method here the then
if the parent can review that somewhere
then say okay now i'm going to go down
the hallway and talk to mrs taylor here
and and find out how she's teaching
fractions or how about how little
johnny's doing oh yeah and and uh to
follow that up and say
where my problem has been when i've been
um an elementary principal
parents would get really torqued off
by the end of fourth grade kids still
didn't know their multiplication tables
right and that was a commonly known fact
that by the time you leave fourth grade
you should know those times tables and
be able to do some long division
and so they come in and say okay what
are the expectations the established
goals for mathematics at the fourth
grade
and we would let them know by christmas
time we expect them to have this stuff
because we got to get under other things
various principles of relationships
between numbers associative cumulative
principles and all that
so um but i'm correct you're right i'm
correct that they don't need to have the
titles of the worksheet that they're
using no no no and you know as a teacher
i'd follow up and say okay what kind of
materials can i use at home to help my
child i'm not to help
and i'm sure the teacher would say
anything you can do will help
so but you're right you're right and
saying what you i agree
any further representative hall
uh yes thank you um
is
now i'm more confused than i was when we
started is the onus on this going to be
mostly
the sau the school board or whatever is
it going to be on the individual teacher
is this really about the teacher
providing the materials they're using or
is this really about
as representative
you've got the curriculum is up online
your competencies are up online
i mean how involved are the individual
teachers be teachers going to be in this
bill
is this about individual teachers or is
it about
the sau is it about the school board
even though it says school board what is
what are we talking about right i i
don't think it's uh uh necessarily the
teacher upon request um
the school board shall have available so
you know would be in the school
administrative office or the district
office uh this material i would expect
or or online
that's what i thought to start with but
then it sounded like it was getting to
be more of a teacher thing
representative luno
thank you mr chair so um
following on on what representative um
paul just um
just asked about um what what does this
all mean i i think looking at the
existing
paragraph roman 2
where where a school board shall
establish instructional policies
that establish instructional goals based
upon available information about the
knowledge and skills pupils will need in
the future
that that that i think has has
has has a
a
a grounded
definition
uh because it talks about the knowledge
and skills pupils will need in the
future
so so instructional goals for the
knowledge and skills that students would
need in the future but then in the
in the bold
section
the instructional goals used for
providing students learning experiences
so
so if we if we try to sort of tie
that back to what the instructional
goals are
i don't see how the
the bold doesn't work for me it it sort
of it sounds
um
it's a term we've used before
gobbledygook
it just sounds thank you
no well
rick i know you've been doing a lot of
driving at a lot of late nights
yeah and i just had a call from the
commissioner of agriculture and i got to
meet with him in another half hour
before the trustee meeting starts up in
another hour
so so if there's
if there's potential for working on this
amendment i'm open to doing that so we
can just move on let's do that and and
come back to this if we can come back
with something that you know
that we're all recognizing that
i think there should be some kind of a
a statement saying yeah parent we we
support providing materials educational
goals that lead to the desired outcomes
or that are the outcomes
so i'm all for that
but i uh let's work on it and bring it
back and
get something
we could sit here talking over education
ease here for a long time
um and that's where we've been in past
years the difference between standards
we had educational standards academic
standards instructional standards and
you know we tried to get it down so we
just have academic standards because
it's it's impossible trying to follow
the thinking of past legislators or even
present legislators so
um so
mr chairman did you have to leave it
now or three o'clock no i gotta i got to
have a meeting uh at least by a quarter
after the hour
with uh
speaker jasper or commissioner jasper
before i go into a meeting with this
speaker and other trustees at 3 30.
so we could try to take up another bill
oh yeah i would like to if we could so
maybe what we ought to do is just put
this one on hold we'll bring it up
there was a motion on the table we just
bring it up at the with the same motion
and go from there
and i will withdraw this amendment at
this time
and so that we can bring forward another
amendment
for the bill
okay
1605 requiring saus to maintain a report
on the five-year projection of future
enrollments
uh representative hobson recognized for
a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to motion
make a motion that
uh we otp 1605.
represent like us
a second
okay we have a motion on the table
representative hobson are you making the
motion would you like to discuss it at
all
uh sure i'll discuss it at all uh
this information is constantly being
assessed whether through regional
planning commissions
projections that the school makes
themselves
private businesses make these
projections regularly and i believe
districts are already doing this
i think it would be good business
practice and for this reason i am
putting forward the motion of otp
further discussion
she said it represent poem
yeah thank you i mean
i remember when i was a slackman we
always got this information from the
regional planning commission so the data
is there
so let's just put it out to the public
is there any reason why the data that
you have there at that time might not be
relevant three years down the road
yeah
so what's the purpose of the data
maybe i shouldn't ask these questions
[Laughter]
mr chair i believe you were instrumental
in the motion making i was
yeah i had um vote your conscience
represent porter don't they already do
this
isn't this already done
it isn't done
you should not talk about the five-year
projection
yeah i'm talking about the five-year
projection don't they don't they i mean
don't i remember being on the school
board and having people tell me we're
looking forward to this many people in
the next five years or whatever
so i think i think 1605 goes beyond that
every every district i think on the last
page of the
of the uh of the school district um
annual report has has
enrollment projections but but to
represent lad's question what are you
going to do with the data well the the
bill answers that question on on lines
13 and 14. i see that to hold each
school district's cost per student
growth within current annual inflation
rate and isn't that a school board
question
and and how can the state how can we
sitting around this table
predict what the what the needs of any
specific school district are
and uh and how in the the um
the bill is also not specific about how
cost per student
is is calculated whether that includes
debt service whether that includes any
other um
use of reserve funds capital reserve
funds that might be used to replace a
roof
does that then come out of curriculum uh
if you if you you know
save a half million dollars to replace a
roof
and um and your enrollment's also gone
down by uh by one percent does that uh
half a million plus one percent come out
of curriculum teacher reductions um
maybe you saved that half a million
dollars because you knew you're going to
have to replace that roof
after after 20 years but that's a local
decision i don't see how we can be
making that around this table
represent woodcock thank you um i was
looking back the notes from the hearing
on 1605 and it made reference to that
same that point the point in line nine
to tip the way the way the calculation
is made and secondly i wonder with the
cost
of
the school district's option
uh you know we have school districts in
this state that are at the minimal level
uh barely can survive the berlin the
klamaths those folks and we have other
places where people live who are paying
twenty thirty forty thousand dollars in
some cases thirty nine thirty eight nine
for the contribution from the schools i
don't think it should be our place to
tell those districts that no you can't
you can't raise your budget over that
one percent level so clearly if i
understand this correctly
that we can't go up over that over the
annual inflation rate
if we want to if we choose to provide
more resources to our school
then we should be able to
is it is how you read that well i don't
see this as capping legislation you
don't
but i i thought we had legislation
elsewhere in law which you know there's
a process to go through and get a
warrant article done to cap this says
budget reduction or consolidation
necessary to hold
that that sounds to me like you're
capping
and it sounds to me like if i live in if
i live over in in uh tough tomorrow
and i want to have a superb resource
commitment to my students then i should
be able to do that if i don't mind
paying for that
but it doesn't say you have to it says
you have a plan that's going to try to
hold
at a certain level it doesn't say that
you're bound there that you you know to
hold
it's this is not the capping legislation
that we have elsewhere in law
oh
this is something where i think we're
trying to i i didn't write it but
i i'm inferring that it is legislation
trying to
establish where we are going
and what is the cost
there their concerns we all have on that
i think that the cost of his district in
my district will be very different based
upon debt based upon
uh
certain circumstances maybe with cat aid
all this is going to make and i don't
want to see comparisons between district
or district like you know
population is the same but how come
yours is increasing so much for that
well you know there's a lot of things
property values everything goes into the
mix absolutely i i think this is that
those lines are going the wrong way uh
rick honestly it's just that that to me
when it says cap and hole and i see this
and make the plan i can just see the the
press in each town saying well one way
or the other we're going to finally get
this done or we're going to cut out 17
teachers three custodians and apparel to
get the plan done and that goes
depending how they want to use that as
it comes to warrant time and budget time
i just think this is i think that
financial part of this piece is is uh uh
significantly uh
impact uh school districts and and and
it's uh not it's not a
val not a good way to go period
for that reason further further
discussion representatives
yeah follow up on what the chairman said
i see this as a transparency issue and a
planning issue
and the school district and the people
in the school district can say cool we
know here's the plan if we want to hold
this
our cost per student within the
inflation rate
so this is the plan for that
but if we decide we want an auditorium
which is going to go over that we can
vote for that this is just this is
this is just to say okay what's been
happening i mean the three-year
um
the posting the cost per pupil of the
previous three years is just
helps to see what the um
what's the word i want the trend thank
you
what the trend has been where we're
going where we're heading if we're
seeing that oh
every year we lose four percent of
students four percent of students four
percent of students at what point does
it make sense to cut a bus to cut a
teacher at what point does it make sense
to cut a school
you know because a lot of
towns ours included built a whole bunch
of stu schools as we had student growth
it's just planning it's just looking at
it it's not saying we have to hold them
it says let's make a plan
so that if we need to we can
unless we decide to do otherwise it's
not telling them they it's
this to me is transparency to the
taxpayers number one and number two
helping the school district plan for the
future by taking a look at what are the
trends what's been happening and what
can we do
if we want to hold our costs down what
can we do what are our options
right what are our options we can vote
not to do that but what are our options
and i think this is a very useful tool
okay representative tanner
thank you um i've served on the school
budget committee at centipede for a
number of years now
and
that's where the transparency is i mean
we we have open meetings we discuss
every little bit of the budget in fact
you know when i first moved to new
hampshire and i wasn't
i wasn't familiar with the school town
meeting
thing of new hampshire
i was blown away
the first school meeting i went after i
was hired as a teacher
they were discussing toilet paper
what kind of toilet paper they were
going to use in the schools and how much
it was going to cost i i
had never been at that level of
transparency before and probably never
want to be again but
that's
school when you're on the budget
committee you do and you take into
consideration how many students you have
this
for me
is um again kind of a big brother issue
it's taking things that should happen at
our local school district levels
if if
you know schools have the budget
committees they've got a budget process
there's an election process there's a
warrant article process there's all
kinds of processes for people to look at
the money and to find out
you know where every dollar is being
spent and i just think this is
overkill and it's overkill unnecessary
and i think it does
put a cap
on budgets this stuff is being done
and and representative tanner is
absolutely correct the whether you have
a budget committee or a budget advisory
committee working with your your
superintendent administration i would
never go out and say well i'm just going
to go out by another 66 passenger
elementary school bus without knowing
where the projections are
down the road and
in what my indebtedness is going to look
like
we do it with our school building aid
too you're not going to get any school
building aid in the state and remember
the capital improvement plan we just put
together where we have to identify um
all these issues of demographics of
capacity space we're using how we're
maintaining all that is part of the plan
so to infer somehow that we're not doing
this we're just handing out a budget
this given year and next year we'll do
the same thing they're all linked i
asked our our superintendent
several nights ago at a school board
meeting where are our demographics and
laura was eight lori was able to give me
an outline where we come and where we're
going and that projection data is there
if you if you walk into the
superintendent's office and ask for it
you'll get it
and because i i it's one of those basic
things that's uh part of uh education
finance
so
and it's available
it's available yes representatives you
have me totally confused
um
and the big brother thing has me totally
confused too it says the school
administrative unit shall prepare it for
the school board
i don't understand a how that's big
brother b how that's telling anybody how
to spend their money
etc i mean it's just the school
administrative unit and partly
yeah
that could be helped by or done by the
budget committee or whatever it is
however your school is set up and it's
different in different towns how that's
done
but also because this administrative
unit part of the plan part is i remember
our budget committee out of the la at
our last school district meeting had
planned big cuts and they just said
across the board cuts
and it was up to the school district to
decide how they wanted to cut them while
they put those back in and we'll see how
the vote goes but
um
but it seems like the school
administrative unit as a whole is going
to be the one that's going to be better
able to make those plans to say you know
we can probably do this but we don't
really want to do that
so that seems reasonable for them to be
the one presenting the plan
and
you know i don't understand this is just
a a local within the school
administrative unit for the school board
it's it's saying communication needs to
happen
communication with the governance of
that particular unit
the the
yeah this the school board and the
administration
you have the legislature out here which
is the body that elects the
governance or the school board and
internally now we're getting down in the
internal workings of how local
districts are administered and operate
and i think that that is
again we're getting into the
micromanagement
of our of our
our school units i i it's being done
yes
i was just wondering i didn't see it in
the
yellow book
but it repeals section 194
c4 that's the goal
and the sun's going down
is there any further discussion here
what's the motion on the table
okay um
is there any further discussion vote
your conscience
uh any further discussion on the bill
madam clerk
house bill 1605 requiring saus to
maintain a report on the five-year
production of future enrollments
the motion on the table is ought to pass
representative cordelli
no
representative litchfield is no
representative boehm
representative lacus
representative leckus is undecided darn
i know i hate these
i'm going to say yes
from zen moffat
my conscience says no
absent hobson
um i made the motion so
yes well you just you just made the
motion so we could vote on it right
um representative ford
no
representative saudi no
representative nelson
representative luna
no
representative waltz no
representative cornell no
representative tanner
no
representative ellison
represent mullen
no
representative woodcock
represent porter
representative hall no
and chairman ladd no
so octopass fails 16 to 3.
okay
i'll make a motion
uh chairman land itl second
we have a
motion in a second uh any discussion
thank you
madam chairman madame clerk
yeah right
okay so the motion on the table for 1605
is now
itl
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative baum yes
representative lacus
i'll be consistent no
representative moffett
yes
hobson
represent ford yes representative soti
yes
rem nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes
representative mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman lodge
so the motion of itl carries 18 to 1.
is there any problem with consent
thank you
11 13
next bill
prohibiting the department of education
the state board of education from
directing or limiting school
instructional options such as remote
learning
if it makes any difference mr chair i do
have an amendment
is there an amendment on this one
was there a yes or no
um
what we'll do is we'll
listen to your amendment without any
kind of emotion made to it
just discussion
i had sent it around
prior via email and this is just the
copy that's all
do you have the number for that
yes
zero three zero nine h
and the amendment simply puts the
language in a different section of law
where we thought it fit better that's
all and that's all i'm going to say
okay
okay so does everybody have a copy of
that
sir any further discussion on this
amendment we've heard representative
porter indicate that
the bold is the same but in a different
area of statute is that what you're
saying
the effect of the language is the same
the words aren't exactly the same
okay represent you
yeah
um
yeah i have a
problem with the amendment in that um
it
changes the title
um it changes the location in statute
and has a different content
i
question whether it is germaine
okay let's uh just take this thing one
step further so we don't have to go
through that process um
is there a motion because we have no
motion on the table right now uh from uh
represent cordelli yes i vote itl
and represent hobson
so we have a motion on the table to itl
1113 made by represent cordelli and
second by reps the hops and represent
cordeli
you're recognized to speak to your
motion
thank you
i think that the
deep bill
goes
too far in in terms of uh remote
learning
i think it contradicts
and undermines uh
rules that were just uh put in place uh
last week i believe
um with the state board um
and for those reasons i will um make my
motion
further discussion reps on boom yeah
just add on i mean remote the learning
was done because of an emergency so i
don't think it should be something that
we can do it all the time thank you
further discussion
yes yeah thank you very much mr chair so
how does this work when it comes to um
velox
throw it out there
i'm
i'm familiar with that you know vlax
course virtual learning academy a
charter school
um
so that's all remote right it's all
remote but it is chartered as an online
school
so that it would you know there would
technically they wouldn't have any days
off they could just do it at home and
then they send it in and get approval
from the velax or they'd get zero days
because charter schools also have a um
have a
a a day's attendance requirement
i'd have to look at i'm not up on speed
on felix
maybe maybe miss fenton
oh yeah i'd have to look it up also
yes reps to hobson
this is this is just my perspective
um
looking at some of the testimony we were
presented
for 1113
the results for remote versus in person
were
were much different um and and as far as
vlax goes
vlax
this is their business they've created
their craft they've perfected their
craft with remote instruction i don't
know that
um
regular in-person school is at that
level yet
that's just my my opinion
mr chair or women represent porter did
have her hand up i'd really like to
speak to my bill and to my amendment um
this bill was originally brought forward
when we were still having
surges of covid
in schools and at that time
it was an option
for schools to be able to go remote for
a day or two
so that they could keep
so that the kids could be safe the staff
could be safe
and there they could maintain the number
of people they needed in the building to
run effectively so if there were too
many staff members out
they would close the building for safety
sake
then the rule came down that they could
not do that anymore
and the reason given was
to talk about remote learning over long
periods of time being detrimental to the
learning of students
which was
which was testimony that was given but
it missed the point of the bill the
point of the bill was to allow the
school districts to be nimble and turn
on a dime when they needed to for a day
or two so that they could keep the
safety of the children in line
the department of education has says
they can use remote learning if it's a
snow day
but they can't use remote learning if
three quarters of the staff is out if
three-quarters of the staff is out they
still have to meet
or they close the school and make it up
at the end of the year
and if you've been in a classroom you
know it's better to continue the
instruction
day after day
to make sure that and not have a gap if
you can do it because what happens at
the end of the year is usually not very
beneficial to the learning of the
children
so this bill was brought forward so that
schools could
when they need to
close and go remote for a day or two
to make sure that things were safe
and i think the testimony that was
brought forth about months of remote
learning damaging children was missing
the point of the bill
and that's why we changed with the
amendment we put it in
to the section that dealt with
the number of school days
and hours that needed to be met for the
school so as much as i respect your all
your opinions the point of the bill was
to allow districts to stay safe and
nimble and do what was best for them
when they needed to and now that has
been taken away by a rule
but
legislation trumps rules
if god bless us we're hoping it doesn't
happen
but if three months from now we have
another major surge of covet
and schools have to
close down
they're going to be going to school in
the summer time
how are they going to make up all those
days and the department the
department said oh well they can just
ask to have those days waived
well
have the days waived wouldn't it be
better to meet for a day or two
remotely than to give it up all together
so that's why this bill is forward vote
your conscience
thank you
uh for you represent porter is this
contingent upon with approval of the
commissioner
no it's not
represented waltz
cute
you know i look at this as one of those
things when the rules are promulgated
it's a set of rules with unintended
consequences and you know
we all know that everybody hated how
many how many days there was remote
education i think everybody out there
understands remote education is a bad
choice
but i'm going to put out there that
there are other emergencies that we
can't see coming and you know i was
watching the news this morning and they
talked about the fact that russia's got
the nuclear bomb and there's serious
concern that they may use it in this
ukraine conflict so if they blow up a
nuclear bomb and we need to keep some of
our kids indoors for a month or
something because it's dangerous to let
them out of the house
they can't go to school so long as that
rule stays in place
so i think by passing something like one
of these bills
it takes away that rule that was really
vindictive
and and let's look at something that
gives educators the flexibility they
need for those things we can't even see
coming
and to leave that kind of rule in place
when there could be emergencies out
there that we can't even see coming i
think is really short-sighted and
ideological and i would recommend that
we pass one or the other versions of
this bill so that we give the educators
the flexibility they need frankly i am
not at all worried about educators
trying to go to remote more than they
should because the teachers the kids the
administrators everybody hates it and
they're going to only use it if they
absolutely have to but there are things
out there there are emergencies out
there that we can't even imagine and i
think we should let the educators have
the flexibility they need to address
them
represent boom
thank you mr chair i think what's
happening now we have rules that can
change and i think by putting it in law
like this
schools can just say hey we're just
going to go remote no matter what
so rather than a law let's do it what
we're doing now
so
if something happened just like the rule
just came out you don't can't do remote
if we have another emergency
it can be an emergency and the rules
would change or the government declares
an emergency then we can do remote by
putting in a law it just says
they can do it whenever they want and
that's not what we should do thank you
yeah i addressed it mr chairman just go
ahead i don't think you could do rule
making fast enough in the case of a real
emergency like the one i described i
think we ought to leave local control
leave it in the hands of the
administrators who are going to have to
make these very short decisions
yes representative
who's handsome tanner
um i haven't talked to a teacher yet
who thought remote was a good idea
i haven't talked to an administrator or
a superintendent who said oh yeah i
think next week we'll just go remote
just for the heck of it
those people that went remote and had to
go remote
were working 8 9 10 11 hours because
some parents
you know had to work
and
and their kids were at home and
they ended up working on their their
assignments in the evening and they
would call the teacher
and the teacher had to provide remote
instruction
after after normal school hours
we also know because of
blizzard bags i don't know if all of you
are aware of blizzard bags but
one year when we had an exceptional
amount of snow days
our school decided
that they would set up a program called
blizzard bags
and in those bags were
each teacher was to make up three
blizzard bags with activities and
studies for students to do and good
instructions for their parents and
some fun things and
they took them home
and when a snow day was called
if a certain percentage i think it was
like if 80 percent of the class
brought in the work from the blizzard
bag
the school would get
credit for that day of school
and the rationale behind it is as
everybody else is kind of chimed in
is that continuity is great is is
really important and we know one of the
things with remote was
the loss of connection
and also the loss of continuity
and if there's an opportunity
to um
scrub down a place just like we had here
although they didn't thoroughly scrub
the place but
if
the school has to has to go out
and and we had situations where we had
influenza outbreaks where we had up to
40 of our student body not show up
because they were sick
they called school for a long weekend so
that they could get in and really do an
uh disinfectant
in the school
that was before we had remote
and it was uh
it broke up the school i mean broke up
the school year and and whatever class
you were teaching you now had another
day
so i think um
you know i think it was
not i think you used the word vindict i
don't think it was vindictive as much as
it was a knee-jerk reaction to
these schools aren't going back to
school fast enough for
a lot of people and so they must be
doing it on purpose well
i don't think schools did it on purpose
and
i would strongly support
the action on this to give a clear
message
that um it's not on purpose and it and
it needs to be
keep
for the local control to make the
decisions when needed
okay i'm going to allow for a couple
more and then i'm i'm going to have to
close or you know either take some
action or we're just going to have to
delay this thing because i got to get
out of here
um represent would talk
thank you chairman lad i'll keep it
brief
this is no more this this bill is so
important to local control we heard all
during all during the last year by the
governor and the commissioner let the
local community decide they know how the
school they know the situation
all the way through local local let them
do it now all of a sudden boom you come
back with nope let's just make it cast
in stone that that makes no sense to me
uh everyone here in this room knows how
how horrible remote was for the amount
of period time but we don't know how
horrible it is if we have three days in
a row where the high school roof
collapses
or
come in thank you come the end of the
year well we're not going to count those
three days that's a budget issue because
the staff's not going to be paid three
more days and they're not going to be
money there
this is clearly a local educational
option how you teach what you teach when
you teach that's what this is we heard
that all year long from the governor all
year long for the commissioner and all
of a sudden boom oh no we can't do it
leave it where it should be
further discussion represent cordelia
thank you
um
distance education may be offered
only due to the snow day as was
discussed number two is an option for a
parent or guardian making a request for
distance education
so if there's an outbreak let's say in a
classroom
a parent could go to the school board
and said i want my
child out i want them to do remote
that's
in the in the rules now um i think the
concern
i'm sorry wait a minute please let me
finish
um the concern um that was discussed i i
imagine within the department and
certainly within the board was what has
happened in terms of uh remote
instruction and the uh loss of learning
that we saw and the nation saw
we have um
in statute with
esser
the ability 20 percent of sr-3 was
supposed to be
directed to recovery of learning loss
you know i i want to look at that to see
how much is actually taking place in
that regard i don't think much
but
there have been estimates of half a year
of math
learning loss um in the state i believe
the learning proficiency in math dropped
from 48 to 38 percent i think that this
is an attempt to say that we are going
to focus on in-person instruction and
that is what matters but provide an
option um for parents to go remote if
they feel it's necessary for their child
just to follow up to represent
cordelia's piece i understand what
you're saying glenn no one likes remote
no one thought it was valid i understand
that but the parents going to the school
board to say we want kids up that
doesn't cut it that's way too long a
distance there's two three four five
these superintendents have to make
decisions based on what happens then
what's in the best interest of a
thousand kids in the school period if
one youngster parent doesn't want to
send the kid to school they don't send
them to school
we're talking about the school system
have a chance to keep up with what's
happening in their community the
commissioner can't do it the governor
can't do it because they're not there
that's why you have a local school board
a local superintendent this is local
it makes no sense
representing moffat
thank you miss chair the the reason that
this rule came about with regard to
remote learning is because of what's
happened in many places like nashua
nashua shut their doors for a year
sorry nashua shut their doors for a year
and that you wonder why a lot of folks
on that way want efas it's because the
the remote option
in the view of many was abused so that's
where that rule came about i hear you
about i agree with you about local
control but just you understand look at
nashua and then try to understand how
this rule came about
mr chair
yes
if you look at the amendment that i gave
it deals with
180 days of instruction
it deals with emergency situations
that's why the amendment came forward
this bill is not talking about closing
the schools down for a year unless god
forbid we have a nuclear war and it has
to happen
this bill is talking about
two or three days they need to close
down to make sure that the school is
safe the students are safe the staff is
safe
is there any further discussion
represent like us
i just wanted to respond and i didn't
say i don't see anything that says two
or three days it just says 180 days so
nashua could use this and do remote 180
days like they did
rep samoan i i just want to say
something before we close this hearing
you
you've heard it said over and over and
over again public school teachers do not
want to be out of the classroom they
want to be in their classrooms it is a
much more manageable and fulfilling job
to be in the room with your students on
a daily basis
we can't go back and redo the history of
the past couple of years we can't go
back when people were absolutely
terrified and that was all of us
to leave our homes because we didn't
know what we were dealing with i think
schools did the best job that they could
but different communities had different
degrees of outbreak on and off
i
i i'm afraid that we're throwing the
baby out with the bathwater and that
we're not going to have the opportunity
a good opportunity that schools can use
with permission from their local boards
to be able to respond in a way that
allows for
the well-being of everybody whether it's
that you know the river floods or uh i
don't know where you were last night but
i thought my roof was coming off
so i i would just ask you
to not
pre-judge
thinking that somehow or another these
classroom teachers don't want to be in
their classrooms i've talked to so many
of them
and they have been almost a single voice
in being absolutely delighted to be back
at school
thank you
not seeing any more discussion madam
clerk will you please call the rule
yes this is house bill 1113 prohibiting
the department of education and the
state board of education from directing
or limiting school instructional options
such as remote learning motion on the
table is ito representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative
representative lacus yes represent
moffett yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford
yes representative sodi yes
representative nelson yes
no rep sam waltz
no
representative cornell no
representative tanner
no representative allison
represent no representative woodcock no
president porter representative paul no
chairman ladd yes so the itl carries 10
to 9.
mr chair i'll write the minority report
and i will have a floor amendment when
we go to the floor
can we not do that right
yeah i'd like to very much but
sean should be out there waiting for him
well we can do that quickly too but i
can't do it right now oh no no i i've
got so what we're going to do is we're
going to close this excession down
and we'll all pick this up those that
come tomorrow for the hearing on the
bills dealing with masks
and vacs and um will
will be here
rather than in repsol
yeah we will be doing it here and we'll
have an overflow room ready if it's
necessary where it'll be streamed aside
so we have it all happening in one
location where the tech people can give
us the support we need
and where we have security downstairs
no amendments are coming up tomorrow for
exacting we will do that all the next
time we meet and we're going to have
roughly around 25 bills which we're
going to have to address
on the 7th
session
and we're trying to give you all next
week off thank you
not really
oh okay
[Music]
thank you mike i totally
right there
and it wasn't just nashville